there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock all right welcome back people
next shows coming up right now this
one's about what's about Jenny freaks
freak shows and sideshow yeah I've been
wanting to do this forever yeah it's
gonna be a good show it's gonna be a
good job Jenny told me about it you know
and I I know a bit about the the subject
and you know we have friends who work at
Disney that actually back in the day
probably would have been in shows like
this now that his plane he walks and
stuff my boy how you doing Tito he's a
walk at a professional a walk he plays a
minion as well yeah yes right but yeah
this is um this is a topic that I think
has been on my list since we first
started talking about doing this show
like however many like two years ago or
whatever it was two and a half years ago
and because this is something that's
always been like really a fascinating
topic for me like I love like all the
[ __ ] around like carny life like all the
lingo it's like there's something like
kind of I know this little weird thing
to say but it's like there's something
kind of like almost romantic about it
yeah you guys grew up seeing that old
horror movie called funhouse with tad
yeah name wasn't Ted Chavez the one in
the jar wasn't it yeah I think it was
yeah but there's a lot a lot of carny
culture shows up in that damn movie and
you know that was also movies yeah yeah
did I get that one on blu-ray yeah I
think we do have no blu-ray or DVD at
camera because we reviewed it like yeah
a while back I think I got it that's
what I was thinking up to because one
thing that you see a lot like in your
old timey freak shows was that you know
they would have these like little it's
it's you know it's called a bullet where
it's just like a circle of color and it
said alive on it because there were some
shows that were like perhaps not as
reputable and they would have like you
know paintings like out on their banner
line of like world's smallest horse or
whatever
it was but then it was like dead and it
was like in a jar and I guess people
felt like they were getting ripped off
so whenever they had somebody it was
just like a you know alligator man or
whatever it was which is usually like a
guy with a skin condition then they
would put like alive on there so they
would know so that so the thing for him
like tobe Hooper spawn house is very
that was kind of like you're talking out
there that would say you know well like
I said I've always really liked the
whole culture surrounding it and I might
kind of go into a little bit cuz not
that far from here there's a town called
Gibsonton or they call it Gib town
sometimes like for short
I think it's 1012 miles south of Tampa
like where I used to live and that's
kind of where all the carny people like
all the show people and stuff like that
would winter so and they and they had
like I don't know I think it's kind of
like gone downhill now because you know
they don't really do sideshows to a
great extent anymore so but they used to
have like all these special laws in the
town where like they were allowed to
like keep and train like exotic animals
like in their yards and like that you
could fix all their rides and you know
the all of it they had the post office
there that had like really really low
you know counters for like all the
little people that live there and stuff
like that so I thought I always thought
that was kind of cool when I was a
little kid out in California I caught
the very end of the circus era yeah and
the only one I really remember seeing
was Ringling Brothers and Barnum and
Bailey Circus yeah I saw that when I was
again that would come and that would
come to California I think a couple
times a year and I'd probably seen it
two or three times and to be and I was a
little kid maybe six seven and be honest
I didn't really like them yeah I didn't
think there was much to him they were
kind of they were kind of boring even
back then for a kid I feel like they now
did the circus cuz I remember going to a
circus when I was a kid but I don't
remember there being aside what a
sideshow from what I remember you were
in this big tent you know and it bring
animals out and they do stupid crap and
then the only thing that I really liked
about it frog but I remember liking were
the clowns
yeah clowns and acrobats yeah acrobats
yeah and now that I'm a little bit older
you know no one and elephants and [ __ ]
shouldn't be living in traveling
circuses no yeah not a minute in India
they've been used as work animals for a
long time you know but they're at least
outside you know yeah going on tour I
think it's too hard for them animals but
this culture came from a time before
television so I guess you could say the
American country people had to have
something to look forward to
so circuses and carnivals are coming to
town yeah it really does seem like the
heyday particularly the heyday of
sideshows was kind of like they probably
started you know obviously it's freak
shows and things like that which I'll
kind of get into in a minute but that's
been going on since you know time
immemorial fifteen sixteenth century but
I think like the heyday of it was like
the mid nineteenth century in the United
States anyway mid nineteenth century
although I think when there was the most
sideshows and dime museums and things
like that was like between the first and
second world war yeah but like you said
once the advent of television came along
and you know people could see other
things yeah you just couldn't really
compete with telling you couldn't really
yeah and it's like even it kind of makes
me sad because like I said I've always
been kind of fascinated with that with
that culture and there are some people
that are trying to continue it I mean
they do actually still have a permanent
you know sideshow what they call a
ten-in-one which I'll explain in a
minute but they have one of those at
Coney Island and it's called sideshows
by the seashore and they actually have
mostly it's not and they also have a
sideshow school like I think it's
fifteen hundred dollars for like three
days or four days and they do like an
intensive training they teach you how to
like swallow swords and do fire eating
and all that kind of stuff and you know
and then they have most of their like
sideshow performers though are what they
call working acts which are you know
people like I said people who swallow
swords or eat glass or do something like
that they don't have a lot of what they
call natural borns which are people with
disabilities essentially that would want
to you know well they got a way to make
income now is
do that right see I feel like back in
the day and I kind of want to get into
that a little bit too is that there was
a lot of controversy starting probably
in the 1920s or 1930s like once you know
medical science started to recognize
like what you know what disease is what
disabilities what a lot of this stuff
was I think people started to feel bad
about going to see them like that like
gawking at them like in a carnival like
it seemed a little like distasteful but
the problem was that at that time there
wasn't really like the social welfare
net where it's like where they had
anything I mean back then it's like this
one event deadweight on a family yeah I
mean back then if you were born with
like you know lobster hands or something
like that it's like you'll probably be
in an institution or you're paired you
know parents would like dump their kids
yes and so they didn't really have a lot
so a lot of the you know quote unquote
freaks themselves which is what a lot of
them called themselves you know they
were like well we don't want you know
the Freak shows to be outlawed because
then we won't have any way to make money
it's like they they liked being
self-sufficient they liked not being a
burden on people it was a scene - yeah
and that's all their friends were from
those same acts yeah they're marrying
and having children and stuff like and
having a relatively normal life yeah cuz
they did that they could be normal in
the traveling freak show shows they
could have their own friends and be
appears and have and have status
yeah in their community of oddities yeah
you know they were into that
yeah because where they gonna do so home
and have their parents take care of them
like an institution somewhere no they
they went for fame yeah and they had
huge egos that's something a lot of you
would understand that freaks had big
egos well yeah like I said and and it
does seem like I mean you know they
weren't you know they weren't all the
same obviously but you know some of them
didn't really like having to do that but
they did felt like didn't have a choice
some of them you know you could argue
that it was exploitative because they
were like he's either sold or given -
yes mom didn't have showrunners like
when they were children and they didn't
really have a choice yeah some didn't
have the intelligence really to make a
choice that's what I was just gonna say
like particularly one of the most famous
ones slit see who was what they would
call back then
pinhead or someone who was microcephalic
he was he's actually quite famous
because he was in the movie freaks from
1932 now he was profoundly mentally
[ __ ] he also he probably had like
the you know mentality of like maybe a
three or four year old child however he
was in he performed for like a very long
time and he really seemed to enjoy it
and all of the other people in the
freakshow were like just thought he was
the coolest person ever because he was
just he was very childlike so he was
like really happy and enthusiastic and
when his caretaker died and he got put
in an institution he was miserable yeah
and so they actually had somebody come
and finally they said you know just let
him go back to what he's used to because
he likes that you know there's kind of
like the modern-day equivalent be if you
ever watch the Howard Stern Show what's
his name he's and he's another microcell
yeah the guy the shrunken head from
Beetlejuice they call him Beetlejuice
yeah that's right I was really and
without the Howard Stern Show and the
fame that and the attention that that
God just wear the languished in
obscurity but yeah even they cared about
it
that's what I mean so in a way like I
can feel you know like when I talk about
you know somebody like Sarah Baartman
like the quote-unquote Hottentot Venus
um she didn't really seem to have a lot
of choice because she was kind of like
sold into slavery and then like she was
illiterate and they were like oh she
signed a contract and said everything
was fine and everything like that so and
she was like putting a cage and [ __ ]
like that because she was African so and
that was something that they did back
then so it's kind of like it's a very
nuanced argument cuz like I said you
know some of the people like you know
depend on the individual it would depend
on the person I mean so you couldn't
really make it was like oh you can't do
that because some of them liked it and
some of them chose that lifestyle
because they said this is the only way
that they could feel normal it's like
they enjoy performing a little clinical
the little people and the Giants were
all in for it you know and they you know
they're and of course they were you know
fully functional they could make it a
choice themselves but if you have any
friends who are little people man their
egos are [ __ ] gigantic back there
they're [ __ ] awesome you know what
they lack of physical size
they make up for nigo it's very funny I
was reading they're hilarious that they
said you know obviously that you know
nothing's universal but they said during
the kind of heydays of the freak shows
and sideshows and stuff they said most
sideshows oddly the giant of the show
and the little person of the show would
be like best buds and they said that
that usually happened because the people
that were giants were usually like
really chill because I guess they didn't
have to be like main or aggressive or
anything like that because they were
already humongous but they're like the
little people tended toward like
pugnacious nests and being like because
you know they were small so they were
used to like having to stand up for
themselves and natural-born entertainers
and stuff like yeah and stuff like that
so so they said like the maybe the
differences in their personalities like
tended to make them because they said
that was something that you saw over and
over again was like the giant and the
little person being y'all have huge
personalities yeah and heaven forbid
there'd be more than one of them in one
spot because then they start turning on
each other and we have had that exact
situation hang on with the Bombers yeah
Tito would just I hate that Tito is kind
of like the little person that goes to I
bar he wants to be the own he wants to
be the only one right when another one
shows up but another one can definitely
start dancing and and it was just all
this he was better looking who's more
who's better than Who who's more
handsome than who who can dance better
than who it just became a [ __ ]
pissing match well it's just kind of
like all the hot girls in the club like
competing like who's gonna get up on the
stage exactly yeah there's like pushing
everybody here so like I'm cuter oh no
get me out of here talk me into throwing
him off the [ __ ] top because man what
you get what you throw me and somebody
else catch me it'll be [ __ ] hilarious
they'll accuse your door crossing I'm
gonna get my EBIT thrown out of here
because a man I did it all the time and
do it all the time just throw me off the
top is my age young man easy
I fell me off the top yeah yeah yeah he
works it yeah he works at Disney please
some Enya needs to be in a walk I think
he volunteers at an animal shelter Wow
yeah I think it's been like several
months at least
but yeah so I kind of want to get more
into it like I said the the show it's I
kind of have a lot of notes but I kind
of because I'm really fascinated with
this stuff so I kind of went all over
the place so I kind of have like a
little bit of a history type thing but
then I have like you know descriptions
like some of the people that I thought
were particularly interesting we'll talk
about PT Barnum and all that kind of
stuff too so it's not super organized
but you know what you guys should be
good with circus I also went to a couple
carnivals that's just different there's
no animals at a carnival yeah but it was
just like games and rides and rides and
ferris wheel and [ __ ] you know it was it
was all kind of shitty yeah and all the
games are rigged every time yeah most of
them are like I you know a lot of the
information that I had because this is
kind of what got me into this this is
this like awesome book right here it's
called secrets of the sideshows by Joe
Nickell which I really recommend if you
don't he's a writer for skeptical
inquirer but he actually um grew up in
in circuses he was like a you know a
talker for a while and he did all kind
of stuff like that so he so he like
knows all about that world and he
interviewed like some really kind of
high up people that have that had been
in it like since the beginning and stuff
so it's like a really really interesting
book and he's got like a lot of great
stories in there that's where that's
where I was reading about the Giants and
the little people yeah us buds and if
you want to see a badass horror moving
from like the early 80s about carnivals
and sideshows see funhouse yeah like we
did a review of it and a review of it
it's a good one it is yeah so before we
do that I just have a couple of very
brief shout outs one of those goes to
Jason for a very generous PayPal
donation so thank you very much for that
always much appreciated also want to say
I don't know if I thanked him before but
Rob sends us so many movies you guys
yeah got all kinds of new ones we got
all kind of each date Susan yeah that's
the one he just sent us so actually
we'll probably review that one yeah
we're behind that just what about the
vampire we got to do 30 days of night as
well because he has also sent us that
yeah so yeah so thank you very much for
all the movies it's like way way much
appreciated and like I said we'll get
around to reviewing all of them
eventually because we had a couple other
ones like in line before that so let's
kind of get into talking about oh
there's no more shoutouts for now
subscribers anything no no no patrons oh
good
nope that's it why did you have any
shout out you wanted to do okay if you
like the show please join us on patreon
we could always use more patrons yep oh
and another thing too I think I said
this on the matinee show um but I'm
gonna start doing because like I said
when when I started doing when we
started doing the matinee show cuz we
first started filming them like in while
we were in the theater so I never did do
like an audio-only version like you know
I mean so for people that listen on
iTunes or just listen you know listen to
us anywhere other than YouTube we're not
getting them so I'm so starting like on
the next episode I'm gonna start doing
that like all the show will be available
on pod so everything I think I'm gonna
do the scary story show I'll just do an
audio there's only a damn podcast what
the [ __ ] does Tom do man what's he
bringing to the show well we don't do
just a show we had other things and
movie reviews and stuff yeah yeah it's
not picking on me man leave Russell
alone we're trying to remake the thing
again trying to step on kruskal's dick I
can't understand yeah should be in it if
they how do they make yeah I mean mm
yeah he's so he's in it then he's still
in good shape he's in it then I'm gonna
go ahead and forgive him I mean he just
played Santa yeah and Christmas radicals
year to ago Andy's making the they're
making a sequel to that yeah I told you
that didn't I oh yeah well did they had
to that's the best Christmas movie of
all times I think it probably might be I
mean well maybe diehard but you know
yeah if that's a person I guess it is I
guess it takes place at Christmas but
there's it yeah Christmas Chronicles
being like a specifically Christmas
movie that's probably one of the best
movies ever I had a good time with it
anyway
so um all right so let's kind of talk
about what we're talking about when we
talk about sideshows and like I said
there's like a whole there's like a
whole carny lingo man
they have like words for everything it's
like a bunch of traveling banded damn
gangsters and gypsies and [ __ ]
see I would say I always found that sign
trick even nowadays it's like you
probably couldn't do it nowadays because
you know that era is kind of over like I
know people have periodically tried to
like bring it back like Jim Rose and
stuff like that came back 90s but you
know he was really successful but even
he I was watching a documentary earlier
as I think it was on the History Channel
or something about the history of
sideshows and they interviewed Jim Rose
on there and he was saying you know they
first came out you know in the early 90s
like and they toured with Lollapalooza
and everything like that but he's saying
you know [ __ ] that worked in the 90s you
know you had mr. lifts oh like lifting
cement blocks with his penis and all
this other kind of stuff it's like you
know that was very edgy for the early
90s not anymore
but not anymore so it's like you have to
kind of constantly keep upping the game
and it's like bringing back carnivals
circuses and sideshows and [ __ ] it's
kind of like equivalent bring him back
Fogg ville it's not gonna happen yes
it's it's you can bring it back but it
won't stick it's not gonna go for it it
can't go viral you can't it's not
difficult to moderate and monetize its a
lot of expenses yeah events on [ __ ]
cash it's just the environment the world
has changed in the environment stop yeah
and like I said it makes so much money
with on so much less now yeah in the
minute you can make a viral dam video
you can be what's that guy's now the
number one youtuber that old PewDiePie
PewDiePie just sits around and makes a
million dollars a month or whatever yeah
right because the world is an unfair
place cuz the world is an unfair place a
carnival would have a hard time making a
million you can do like I said they
still have a traditional sideshow in
Coney Island that's permanent that
doesn't work not to her and it's you can
still do it but it's very nice yeah it
would have it could not tour it would
have to stay in one way because that's
very expensive too expensive and I mean
they still have carnival
and stuff but I think one of the things
that happened you know particularly
after the Second World War was that it
just got cheap like people seem to dig
the rides more than the sideshows and
rides obviously you don't have to pay
them anything you don't have to you know
they're very easy to use machine setup
it's just mechanical you know they're
fairly easy to maintain they're fairly
easy to transport so it seemed like you
know sideshow performers kind of got
pushed out because you know carnivals
were like no which we can put more rides
in that space rather than just having
you know a snake charmer or whatever
that it's like doesn't guarantee we'll
bring in that much money right so I
think that kind of happened to like
people's entertainment options changed
because I feel like some and Joe Nickell
even went into this a little bit in his
book because I think there was a
perception that it's like oh you know
everything went all politically correct
like you weren't allowed to like display
like freaks anymore and stuff like that
and he's like that's really not what
ended up happening it was more like an
economic right kind of thing you know
what I mean you have to pull down so
much money to keep that thing on the
road because even back in the day some
of the bigger carnivals that I
remembered existing didn't they didn't
travel nationwide yeah it's like local
there region it was in it was in a state
or so like a big state like Florida
might have one yeah they might or once a
year you know I mean that's about it we
had one where I grew up in Daytona we
had one that came every October and on
and actually one of my best friends
growing up her parents worked the fair
circuit they were airbrush artists so
for several months a year they would
tour around with different but like you
said it was regional yeah like they
didn't go around the whole entire
country it was usually just like a
quarter of the country and then they
would make all their money for that year
and then they would like nowadays a
carnival like this you might be able to
get that to exist and make money in a
place like say maybe India where it's
got a high population high population
density its kind of lower income it's
outside the cities it's country maybe
the people you know
or they might be more interested in that
you know yeah but I don't think in the
West I've seen the ones that I've seen
that are recent that are still going
around like touring carnivals usually
will stick to like the Midwest or more
rural areas they don't really do the
traditional like I said I'll explain
later but um you know they don't really
do the traditional like ten-in-one
sideshow they usually do what's called a
single Oh which is usually like just one
display like under a tent and like each
person has their own and I noticed that
like a lot of the recent ones tend to be
more like see alien bodies and like
frozen sasquatch it isn't stuff like
that they don't have like a lot of
living exhibits anymore just because of
the expense um you know it's like you
don't want to have to take a
three-legged cow like that's alive like
everybody because you have to feed it
and transport and stuff like that it's a
pain in the ass so most of the carnivals
nowadays have what back in the old days
they would have called a museum show
where everything is like stuffed or
pickled or pickled or something like
that like pickled punks and as they call
them or something like that so but I did
see some like really funny like single
Oh ones for like come see the alien
autopsy like the autopsy bodies and
stuff like that and the whole idea
behind this this whole this whole
marketing ploy is that there ain't [ __ ]
to do where you are so the carnival
comes to your town yeah where the fair
comes near to because there's nothing to
do there right so that you're always
talking about a rural place yeah they
don't have a lot of energy on a dam do I
mean you say well let's go let's go look
at it
yeah you know and they spend a couple
dollars yeah each one of them thousands
of them go they make a few down you know
they make a few thousand dollars a day
or something you know and then they move
on to the next one
really you're not gonna find that in
United States anymore yeah that's gonna
be like India maybe China some kind of a
large developing country with a the
rural pop working population that might
be interested in something like that
there's nothing to do where they are
yeah I mean we're like I said it within
a young population of a bunch of little
kids yeah so you know I mean where I
grew up like I said in Daytona Beach I
don't know if they do it anymore because
I've been back there anymore but we had
a carnival that
came every October that was like a
regional carnival and it didn't have a
sideshow it was basically just games
food concessions and a [ __ ] ton of rides
like the Gravitron and all that other
stuff and it did really well like
everyone would go because you know state
onna back in time back in the 80s there
wasn't anything to do so yeah everybody
would go string 'king regulations too
much probably people walk around with
open containers yeah as far as I
remember yes yeah probably yeah so so
that so it was popular but like I said
it wasn't it was just like a very basic
carnival it was mostly rides and that's
mostly why people went it just brought
for rides and funnel games and [ __ ] like
that there wasn't a sideshow there
wasn't anything like my rides had
protracted more than sideshows and I
think I feel like that is one thing that
killed like the traditional yes sideshow
you know what I mean pleasure ology yeah
well in plus like people liked rides
more but it's like also it's more
efficient I think yeah one two I think
people like are still like uncomfortable
about like looking at you know deformed
people or people with disabled that are
disabled or whatever but you know again
people have seen that and you can just
go online and see that right so it's
like not really that much of a novelty
anymore right um you know so there's I
think a lot of things contributed but
like I said I've always really liked
that kind of that whole aesthetic in the
whole and I guess a lot of people do
because American Horror Story did a
whole [ __ ] season called freak show
that was based on that and it actually
liked a lot of the characters and that
were based on real people although I
think they changed their names like
lobster boy and stuff like that we'll
talk about him in a little bit because
that's a [ __ ] crazy story so as I
said before now we talk about a sideshow
when most people think of a sideshow
what you're thinking of in Carla carny
parlance is what they call a ten-in-one
it's not always ten acts but that's just
kind of what they call it there's such
as like the average and that's basically
just one it's one long tenth and it has
like your banner line outside that has
like all your big banners it says like
what all your performers are inside it's
usually you know human oddities or
freaks or ever you know column and
they usually have like some working acts
as well or people that are what they
call made freaks like the tattooed man
or the fat lady or whatever like kind of
stuff like that so a lot of these are
operated as what they call a grind show
which means that you pay for a ticket
like the shows are like continuous so
you just pay for a ticket and you go in
and then you just watch all the shows
until it's kind of like like you can
come in in the middle but then it'll
start awesome and you yeah it's just
like a constant rotation so that's what
they would call a grind show and what
they usually do is they'll have you know
inside the tent they'd have like each
performer would have like their own area
and you'd have a guy that would like
kind of go through and tell you like who
this performer was and what their deal
was and then they would do whatever
their thing was and then they usually
have little things that they would sell
you like a big thing that they would
have was they'd have like a little card
that had like their picture and then it
had like their life story which was
usually [ __ ] because this stuff is
[ __ ] yeah like a bearded lady was
not a bearded lady I don't believe it
was a man dress hmm there may have been
songs but know a lot of the actual
bearded ladies were they were alone with
women um because I think I saw one and
it was just a man yeah now some of them
were but it's like that was kind of like
um I thought they would all thought
David I thought they must have all been
faked no okay because there is actually
a lot of shit-faced I mean women with
hirsutism would grow a big beard like a
man would yeah and so a lot of the
bearded ladies were actually women okay
I know there were some shows where they
were actually men okay but that was
quite rare the thing about it is that
people that were quote-unquote natural
born freaks in back in the day of like
the sideshows they were kind of
considered like the royalty of the
circus because you couldn't really fake
that yeah you know yeah some of them
were fakes like some kind of more
disreputable sideshows would fake like
say Siamese twins like yes but like they
find you twins and like put them
together with
like that but in general I mean some of
the more famous you know natural born
freaks or human oddities or whatever I
don't really think there's much of a way
you could have faked them particularly
something like you know lobster boy
or monkey girl she was one that was very
famous any was Priscilla or purse Ella
or something like that the monkey girl
who had like a type of hirsutism so she
like had hair all over her body and had
like a yeah like stuff like that you
know or if you're in a date during
during our days when they had carnivals
that had [ __ ] like it was all fake they
didn't have any real freaks in them yeah
yeah I mean I kind of probably would've
liked I seen the real thing yeah in my
lifetime
it was just fake I think by the time cuz
like I said the the heyday of them you
know once after World War Two that you
know the popularity of them started to
decline and also I feel like the advent
of better medical technology and stuff
like that meant that there were less
people with those types of deformities
being born or you know or you know
Siamese twins could more easily be
separated for example so you didn't get
half as much of a pool so I do feel like
the ones that were still around after
that we had more incentive to fake
things because some of those Carnales I
went to had that there's like you you
know I mean where you'd go into like you
said grind show yeah with like like you
said the museum type stuff but from what
I remember it was all fake there's
nothing really stood out in my mind it
was all gags yeah the ones that I saw it
was just even pay much to see it anyway
it was mostly just them putting
something over on you yeah and I feel
like that's like there's a lot of that
when I when I see like more modern ones
like I said when I've seen more modern
ones like a treat more recent carnivals
particularly the ones that were like
alien bodies and stuff like fish with a
like a mermaid which is a damn the
feejee mermaids oh well that's going
back to PT Barnum right that was like I
had that stuff in there I think the
thing about it and it we'll talk a
little bit about PT Barnum later but I
think a lot of people have a little bit
of a misconception about PT Barnum it's
like he did some questionable [ __ ] but
you know the very famous quote that's
attributed to
attributed to him there's a sucker born
every minute there's actually no
evidence that he ever said that and most
people that knew him you know wrote
later that's a that is not something
that he would have said he said some
stuff about getting people in the doors
as quickly as possible and getting but
he had I do remember some of the quotes
I remember that he had a bunch of cool
business quotes I don't remember the
quotes himself do you yeah no yeah I
think I did but it was just like basic
stuff about getting a crowd in and out
very quickly and you know make money
yeah it was just that kind of stuff he
basically was of the opinion that it was
a show that come back yes it was okay to
like have a little bit of [ __ ] in
there as long as people were entertained
as yeah and felt like they got their
money's worth
exactly then he wasn't really worried
about it so a lot of his stuff was
really you know yes he had like a lot of
real human oddities but he would all he
what also wasn't above like you know
poking fun inventing yeah and inventing
like a more exotic backgrounds for the
people like giving them new identity
well that shows more right and and I
think that's kind of how he approached
it and honestly I think that the people
that were going to this to the sideshows
I mean they knew that there was some
[ __ ] involved yeah you know they
were paying for the fun for the
experience there's a long tradition of
that in the United States anyway even
Hollywood yeah if you have it down if
you had an actress who was Mexican give
her a [ __ ] French last name yeah
claim that she came from Paris
yeah sell better yeah yeah you made
whatever you had you made it more exotic
yeah so and that's essentially and
everybody knew they were doing that it
wasn't unusual so it's not like a big
secret and I like that they were
actually like in that Joe Nickell book
he was actually talking to or talking
about this one artist in particular I
think it's his last name is a B or
something like that where he was kind of
like very well known for making these
faked or gaped in carny parlance you
know he would make like sasquatches and
alien bodies and stuff like that and
they were really really good but you
know they're clearly fake but he had
been
it is saying that he's like you know I
don't really think of it as like fake
it's like you know when you go see a
movie
it doesn't say at the beginning like oh
nothing in here really happened like
these people aren't really like spies or
superheroes or anything like that he's
like he's like yeah he's like it's just
an art form so it's like why should I
have to tell people that it's fake you
know what I mean you should know it's
fake right and and I feel like that's
kind of thing so did they have carnival
right so and I think that's funny too
because a lot of times like I said when
they have particularly in the museum
type shows where everything is you know
dead or stuffed or just a photograph or
whatever so obviously they can't put
alive on the banner so they usually will
put real because they said well that's
there like it is real and it's like you
know even if it's real rubber right so
it's like so it's not a lie exactly it's
just you know it's just flim-flam this
is a real statue of a damn right and
that's how they see it it's like a it's
a real photograph the world's tiniest
horse you don't know it's like you know
you have to kind of know what you're
getting into and I think like nowadays
people do know that that's how I
remember the carnival's be ended up that
I went to yeah and I don't even really
remember anything anything and
specifically yeah because they really
weren't that impressed just like okay
yeah you got yeah there's this Park
experience in it yeah most are never
mostly shooting galleries yeah
impossible games that there's no way you
could win yeah I think you could win
like throwing rings over a little over
coke bottles
and every time you got that you got a
certain score and if you got it to a
certain amount like 200 you'd win a big
prize
but then there's like the fine print
every time you throw the ring you get
half you know half points instead of you
know basically what it is is numerically
impossible to [ __ ] score 200 yeah you
know it's just that kind well like I
said that's just like casinos yeah where
it's like even if the games are
legitimate you can't still can't win you
still can't really win them or you know
it will favor the house in the long run
yeah you don't I mean so they do tend to
do things like I was reading about one
particular game where it's not
necessarily rigged it's just that you
know it looks super
like you just roll the ball down an
incline and like just try to knock these
two bottles down but they're like
there's all this stuff they do to make
that almost impossible like the ball is
really light like they'll put one of the
bottles like very slightly in front of
the other one so that'll like kind of
you know absorb the whole thing so it'll
just knock one over and not the other
one it's like they have all these like
little tricks from what I saw the big
winner in the carnival that I went to
was a damn cotton candy machine yeah the
people that can make cotton candy it's
everywhere you just saw cotton candy
damn everywhere and you know for a
dollar you get it thinking cotton candy
it's probably like one penny worth of
sugar yeah one penny I feel like the
food concessions are probably where it's
at yeah because everyone's got to eat
yeah pink cotton candy and blue cotton
candy [ __ ] it everywhere yeah make me
want blue you know maybe you meet you
have like a booth with cotton candy
churros and [ __ ] funnel cakes and you
probably clean up yeah I think that's
that's where I think really the mine was
corndogs yeah I don't remember them
deep-fried Mars bar busy cry everything
at like carnivals in the Midwest I've
heard but yeah so like I said when we
talk about a sideshow mostly they talk
they're talking about attended one um so
as I said you'd go in and you'd have
like the Freak Show they you know they
give you like a little they'd sell you
like a little souvenir cards with like
their picture on it and have like their
story in there when they have like
Giants in the circuses like dudes that
were seven eight nine feet tall they
would usually sell like these really big
rings like a giant's ring that was a
very common thing like a souvenir like
that was like way too big for a normal
human hand you know what I mean so for
some reason that was like a big thing so
you'd go through there and then what
they would usually do is at the end they
have this thing called the blow-off and
that was usually like an extra show
you'd have to pay a little bit extra to
see it but it you know it wasn't ever
any specific thing but they they would
always try to sell it like it was like
super weird or super exotic no women and
children you know cuz it's too upsetting
or yeah you know something like that so
it's like it would usually be like one
of their best
you know performers whether it was like
a natural born freak or whether those
are working
a lot of times they would use like kind
of illusions you know I mean like they'd
have a box that just had like you know
that looked like a woman's head in it or
something like spy Dora yeah that was
like something that was really common to
it was like a big spider body but then
it had like a human head they did it
with mirrors
so it looked like the spider actually
had a woman's head that could like talk
to you and [ __ ] cuz she was really there
it's just yeah it was real it was yeah
it was real and it did it said spider I
really you know I think I think I have a
picture of one of those banners which
might have been painted by Johnny Mia
who was kind of like one of the big he
actually used to be a sword swallower
and he kind of went into like painting
those big banners and he's like probably
most famous one and they interviewed him
for the thing but they yeah they always
built like spread [ __ ] it's like she is
real yes really the same technique
they'd used you and use on little kids
in the damn comic books yeah you inside
there they try to sell you [ __ ] toys
yeah I mean one of the ones that I
bought may have such a disappointment
well I by there's two of them are the
sea monkeys yeah but you're just like
Brian just brine shrimp eggs that's what
it was yeah and then like some salt yeah
you need to put that mix make your own
saltwater brine shrimp would hatch but
[ __ ] you were you're a little kid you
were never gonna wait the 30 days for
the brine shrimp to hatch and they
wouldn't hatch anyway you had to have
perfect saline and stuff you know salt
water contact had to be perfect in the
water yeah and it probably be aerated
you know but the other one that I got
was the the giant footlocker with the
two opposing armies the American army
and like the German army in it yeah and
and their [ __ ] comes in a footlocker and
it's like three by two by four thousands
of [ __ ] man and thousands of
airplanes and [ __ ] when you get it it's
it comes in a damn box like a like a
remember the old checkbook boxes ahead
he checks in it yeah that's how big it
was and then it was printed on the
outside had wood like it yeah like her
box it was 3 inches by 4 inches by 5
inches and all the little troops are
there talking about we're two
dimensional little flat plastic
pictures of them
that you can had to stand up on little
bases I mean like each one of them might
have 20 guys on it you know never do a
two-dimensional tank yeah I mean so you
could stack so and that was the giant
footlocker filled with the whole [ __ ]
Arnett well it was giant compared to the
little dude it just didn't make any
sense see them it was like it was like a
dollar well second I'll get what you pay
for
did you pay it for that way yeah boom
you're a kid you thought a dollar was a
lot of money back then follow that's
true yeah it's funny because you know
people think like the deceptive
advertising
I mean deceptive advertising it goes
back to like the earliest days of
humanity yeah you know what I mean it's
like whatever you can like get over on
people need glasses yes it's like to get
them to like give you their money and
stuff but like I said you know the early
sideshows it's like they promised you
know people with three legs and stuff
like that and there they were there
that's like they weren't fake it's like
even though some of the people did like
like there was this one particular guy I
can't remember his name but he had been
born with like a really really severe
what do you call that [ __ ] cleft palate
yeah so it went like all the way up his
face so like so it was like this and
then like his nose was over here yeah
like that like his half sibs nose and
like that
and it looked like pretty [ __ ] up but
for extra you know for extra [ __ ] he
would draw an extra eye like in the
middle like in the gap just so he could
be like oh he's a three eyed man because
it's like that wasn't freakish enough
like the way his face looks he's like
yeah I would draw like an extra eye in
there and so I could be like a 3i dude I
mean and that's what they put on his
banner you know the three eyed man which
you know what I mean it's like he wasn't
he didn't have three eyes before but he
was he did have those other deformities
that was the only thing that was gaffed
was that one that one either eye which
you know like I said you got to do what
you gotta do man like you said it's
[ __ ] into it it's showbiz it's show
business and a lot of them did that you
know what I mean like I feel like a lot
of them kind of particularly with and
went on tour they give themselves exotic
names like gave himself exotic
backstories
um you know oh my mother was frightened
by an elephant when I was yeah sure I
was in the womb and like all this other
another one that another one that they
had a long they had a long history of
making what they call wild men yeah all
right yeah a wild man could be anything
yeah anybody who is kind of
funny-looking yeah it could be a wild
man and they'd do something like dress
him up into fur like a like a furrow a
loincloth or something put him in like
in a cage and [ __ ]
yeah put him in a cage with a club and
and [ __ ] his hair all up and make him
into a wild man wild man of Borneo and
they they'd even describe where he came
from you know wild man of Peking mmm-hmm
yeah Chinese wild man and just just
everything you know they did they did
that a lot and um they were totally
normal guys almost a lot of them were
yeah um and the thing is too is that you
know particularly sideshows because you
have to kind of admire I mean they're
really kind of resourceful like I said a
lot of the displays aside out of nothing
real but it's like sometimes they come
up short or they're like you know we
need something else so they would take
like the guy that was like the fire
eater or something like that it's like
hey you put on this crazy wig and like
this furloughing cloth and get in there
and scream at the wild man like that so
it's like you'd have to do [ __ ] like
that but like I said it was all in the
story that you told yeah and like I said
if you kind of like wanted to buy into
that fiction it's kind of like read a
novel or like watching a movie or
something that's kind of like how I see
it yeah it's like if you want to buy
into the [ __ ] and like just have a
fun time it was a prototype of what you
would call it a day LARPing this is live
and it's if you're enjoying the LARPing
of this it's entertainment [ __ ]
showbiz yeah that's what I mean so it's
so in a lot of ways I think that was the
most entertaining part of it to me was
the stories they would come up with to
make like I said these people already
had various like disabilities or
deformities or whatever that people were
paying to see but then they would have
to like you know kind of gild the lily I
guess I like coming up with these crazy
[ __ ] stories about why they looked
that way and all this other kind of [ __ ]
just imagine most of it was in the story
yeah
is what sold it yeah and I think PT
Barnum's said something maybe not in
those exact words but that was what he
meant that that's what people were
paying for Marah was the story behind
the person in a way it's like you have
to think you know yes and on the one
issue like I said before you could see
it as exploitative
but in another way and I think you know
the people that were actually in the
sideshows kind of have this attitude
toward it as well they're like one
people are gonna stare at me anyway
saying they might as well pay to do it
and to it's like at least this way I get
to like talk to people and they can ask
me questions like when they come into
the sideshow and they and they find and
they buy my photo but my photo and like
they read my story and stuff like that
so it's like so they're seeing me as a
human being
whereas maybe before they wouldn't have
their spin it in and you're spinning it
into an advantage for you yeah
you now have status yeah you now have in
a way of like an authority yeah
specialty a reason for being there and
if they weren't doing that well I saw
interviews with him yeah I mean they
said without that they wouldn't this or
at least I saw shows that quoted the
interviews right because they're all
dead you know yeah yeah it was a long
time ago yeah they were like you know
what would I have done without the
[ __ ] what I've done with yes a lot of
them had that and to be honest a lot of
them were very successful
I mean General Tom Thumb he will talk
about in a bit when he died quite young
unfortunately but when he died he was a
millionaire yeah their whole lives where
was that sideshow yeah that's where all
their friends were that was their whole
it was the whole family I hope that was
their culture that would that was their
profession that was their self-worth
yeah you have to do something in life
yeah and that's show business man
yeah that's was that's your calling if
you've got a deformity show business
yeah and I can totally understand like
had I been born like that I mean even I
was thinking about like one of the more
modern ones like the sideshow by the
seashore in Coney Island which is still
operating
they actually as far as I know they only
have one
quote-unquote natural-born she is a girl
who has if you've ever seen the movie
freaks and you see and you've seen like
the bird girl okay this girl has that
same thing so she looks very bird-like
and she was born like that so she just
leaned into it she said I want to be
like you know the modern incarnation of
that girl so she goes by cuckoo the bird
girl and she just performs like that
like she wears like big old owl glasses
and like where's the thing with like
feathers and [ __ ] like that on it yeah
so you know and she seems like you know
a lot of them said that that's where
they got like all their self-worth from
cuz like I said people were gonna stare
at them anyway because a lot of their
you know you know deformities I guess
you want to put it that way like
couldn't be covered up like you know
it's kind of hard to cover up if you
have like a third leg or if your face
looks like it's split into air or
something like that and by and by by all
accounts according to them they took
care of each other they were you know
they were they were their own subculture
and everybody looked out yeah and that's
where they could go be with their own
kind and you know that was that was the
only family they had yeah so because
sometimes their actual families have
abandoned abandoned them because of
their you know because of the way they
never get married they had relationships
you know it just was the whole nine you
they were not there were even though
they were unusual they're people like
anyone else they have the same needs
other people have yeah and they were
they were only getting it in that scene
it was a scene yeah and I feel like that
was you know for a lot of them I think
that was like the best situation that
they could have been in because yeah
because yeah back then it's like what
were you gonna if you couldn't work you
know like a regular Joe if you're a
deformity like forbid you from working
it's like we're gonna do they didn't
really have like a social safety net
battling people in that freak show one
of them was like a little a way but not
a dwarf but a [ __ ] yeah he didn't have
any arms or legs yeah
because other than that it was totally
proportionate yeah I don't think it was
dwarfism but how could a guy like that
exist
yeah and live without being in it yeah
yes not Joe cuz he had to have other
people to feed him cuz there was one guy
who was actually quite yeah there was
one guy who's actually quite famous who
went under several
like human caterpillars like that guy
yeah he had like no arms no legs no
anything but he could do pretty much
everything with his mouth yeah he could
roll cigarettes he could you know he'd
shave that's what he would do like on
his he did everything with his mouth you
have to be in a sideshow yeah or that
are you gonna be in a hospital yeah you
know or in some institution what kind of
life is that right I'd much rather be on
a road with other free so good I am
that's what I mean I mean I wanna show
ya talk to people make money and yeah I
have to worry about and like I said a
lot of them particularly PT Barnum you
know even though he may have had some
questionable practices but he did by all
accounts like pay his people very well
and like I said you know General Tom
Thumb who's probably his most famous you
know he actually went on to become his
business partner and he actually got
quite rich from and he got to like
perform for Abraham Lincoln and Victoria
and [ __ ] like that for you guys who
don't know Tom Thumb as he was he was a
not a primordial dwarf but a [ __ ] yeah
maybe someone that very very small still
proportional but very very tiny boy and
he was a good-looking little guy and was
a superstar in his day I mean a megastar
everybody knew who he was they would
write damn newspaper articles you know
who's he seeing who's he going out with
you know because he was engaged to marry
one girl and then another little
elopement they called her mrs. Tom Thumb
or Thumbelina yeah Lavinia Warren her
never worn and she was another little
tiny a little tiny person in perfect
proportions and everything and it was
like a match made in heaven they did get
married they did and evident there was
they were fight they were all that all
the little all the little dwarves and
midgets were fighting over this woman
and she was she was a very beautiful
girl yeah and like I said little people
got huge [ __ ] egos they were slanter
and Eve talking [ __ ] about each other in
the press and fist fights breaking out
there not just cuz they're little
doesn't mean that they're not gonna
fight alright they fight each other it
was very funny because as soon as
Lavinia Warren who ended up being a
Tom Thumb as soon as she ended up
joining the circus or like meeting with
PT Barnum General Tom Thumb whose real
name was Charles Stratton actually but
um as soon as he saw her he was
completely smitten and he goes to PT
Barnum and he says you know I want to
marry her like I you know we're gonna be
engaged in stuff and he's like oh I
already told the press you guys were
engaged to like because that was what
you did it was just kind of like in the
circus like where they'd have like sort
of weddings between like the fat lady
and the human skeleton and stuff like
that it was just for publicity mostly
but um but he was actually super in love
with her however there was another
little person I think his name was
Commodore Nutt and he was super into her
too
so there was like a rivalry going on
like between the two little guys like
for her affections but she did actually
end up marrying you gotta know little
people to understand what's good and in
in our in the in our club that we go to
a tie bar in downtown Orlando a couple
theis they've had midge what they called
[ __ ] wrestling show they have had that
yeah and they have all these warband
guys come in there and start wrestling
put on this huge show and we didn't get
to see it we should yeah I met so we
heard all about it all right and the
women were going crazy over these guys
they were like [ __ ] this super popular
[ __ ] dirty dancing and [ __ ] on the
women and getting up on a damp bar after
the show they just they just took over
the [ __ ] Club show just took over see
I'm sorry we missed it because that's at
least it was one of the best nights yeah
you have to get well next time they come
back whoa I think they do they usually
do it like once a year they put on a
great show evidently and then they just
[ __ ] hear tane yeah and evidently the
way they said the women were going crazy
over his old dudes yeah I guess they're
working out they're doing at Acrobat
yeah you know and like I said they his
DS know how to talk and they got he
[ __ ] egos and [ __ ] you know
grabbin girls asses and stuff and girls
so I can pick him up and put him on a
bar they were evidently making out with
[ __ ] girls and stuff wrestlers yeah I
know it sounds like a good time yeah but
yeah so so yeah that's the thing I'll
probably get a little more into general
toss them later on cuz I think he's like
further down in my notes but uh like I
said this isn't super organized I'm just
gonna go around whatever but like I said
I was talking earlier about the blow-off
which was usually like one super secret
show that he had to like pay extra for
and as I said it was sometimes it was an
illusion you know that just kind of
stayed there
headless women that was you know kind of
a big thing too I might have a picture
of that I think some of those it's all
of it's done with mirrors and all this
other kind of stuff another one that
would usually be in there would be the
quote-unquote pickled punks yeah I love
that name now in the early days of the
sideshows these were usually real
fetuses and they usually had something
they were like - had it or they had some
kind of thing like that but nowadays or
like later on after like after there
were laws passed that you weren't
allowed to like exhibit like what they
would call human corpses or human
remains or anything so there's like you
kind of have like laws in some states
where you're not really allowed to show
them so like in that case they would
have to use something called a bouncer
which rope which is like a rubber or
vinyl one like in a jar and it's like
they'll usually put like tea or coffee
and the water likes to make it a little
bit cloud they see can't exactly see
that it's not real you see that movie
fun house they got pickle Fox in it yeah
yeah please tell me there's a band
called the pickled punks
there's gotta be yeah I mean cuz that's
just that's such a great [ __ ] name I
don't think people know but know what
that means yeah maybe not I I actually
didn't know that term like I had read
that book a long time ago but I reread
it like before we did the show and it's
like when I was I was like oh yeah the
hawk means different things different
people you know to white people it's
these guys with Mohawks that [ __ ]
they're in bands - black people a punk
is a prison homosexual yeah yeah and I
think that was the original meaning
as far as I know yes I mean it might
have had more than one meaning but I
think that that was the meaning that it
started out right there as far as I can
recall and lets you know yeah maybe some
other word nerds out there can correct
me if I'm wrong but um yeah so as I was
saying before you got your ten and one
you know with the blow-off and
everything like that they also have like
another type of attraction which I think
I mentioned before is called a single oh
and that's usually just like one tenth
with one you know one display now this
is usually something like it'll be like
one kind of impressive saying one
popular thing is Bonnie and Clyde's
death car
Hitler's car you know obviously most of
them are not real um another popular one
is a giant rat which is usually a copy
bara or a nutria because most people
have not seen those like in real life
so um yes a capybara is much bigger than
an interesting them both yeah um I I
feel like copy bars are more common
because I've from what I've heard from
carny people is that copy bars are a lot
more chilled out yeah they're nice pass
whereas nutria czar like mean they're
like really aggressive and they're kind
of hard to control and a nutria looks
does look like a rat doesn't really
really that's what I always lie on a
giant looks like a giant gopher yeah it
doesn't have a big long tail for a giant
gopher doesn't sound as cool as just
right right okay right but you can go
out and pimp had a copy bar you can pin
a while with capybara yeah there in
Brazil you know yeah they're very chill
there yeah you can put a wild capybara
they usually don't give you that's why
they usually is he like dogs yeah and
they can hang out with a dog and they're
just they're chilled oh yeah another
thing they would usually do like I said
they would have something like a Fiji
mermaid which that's going back to PT
Barnum I mean that was one of his gaffes
he said it was a mermaid but it was
actually like the top half of like a
baby monkey like sewn into like a salmon
tail or something like that so a lot of
people have made kind of why just let me
to think of that they made fakes of it
so well it the original was a fake - it
was a fake but you know nowadays it's
like they'll have like one
kind of modern sideshow that I saw like
in a documentary and he and me hatch and
he had one that he that he called the
Fiji mermaid but they have like little
signs next to it going you know is it
real is it fake we just think it's cool
you know what I mean so it's like they
they pretty much acknowledge that it's
not real I mean obviously everything I
saw in the carnivals it was like that
was it was the joke was on you yeah you
know but Utica yeah it's okay but you
only paid a quarter that's what I mean
my number like really yeah you only paid
a quarter and they showed you a bunch of
funny [ __ ] and told jokes and then you
went out the back yeah I mean I think
the one now the one that they have on
Coney Island I think last time I checked
I checked I think it was $10 to get in
but it's about a 45-minute an hour show
okay so you see like 10 to 12 performers
like I said this is mostly performers
there is one natural born in it that has
the cuckoo the bird girl but they
usually have like fire-eaters glasses
sword swallowers like people that do
that kind of stuff aerialists you know
so it's it's mostly what they would call
working acts like you know and they also
have as I said they also have a school
that you can go to because I was reading
an article and I think it was on Vox
and the girl that wrote the article
actually had the lobster boy thing
lobster claws syndrome like on one of
her hands yes so the the guy that ran
the school was talking about how unusual
it was that they didn't have like a lot
of natural forms in there anymore that
she actually had that with her hand
there was a newscaster woman that had
that yeah she was really gorgeous look
like a damn it's called ecto Doug Leier
yeah something like that she looked like
a model yeah and they didn't ever keep
her hands in camera yeah and then but
you know eventually came out that she
had that babies yes yeah it's pretty
rare I think I read that it was like
from that Vox article I think I remember
she said it's only one in 90 thousand
birds so not as uncommon as I would have
thought but still pretty rare yeah and I
don't think that it's something they can
see like I said this girl that wrote
this article she only had she just had
one hand like that
look manatee you think it was something
they can fix almost you priced separate
those fingers out I guess it depends on
how bad it is on yeah because if you
look at somebody like
sir boy I didn't have very many bones
who lobster boy he had it was both of
his hands and both his feet okay like he
didn't I don't even think he even had
legs I think if his legs were like
really short but his hands and his feet
were both like that and they were fused
so it wasn't even like the fingers were
fused together it was just like two big
fat fingers okay you know what I mean so
it didn't even look like it was fused
okay now that and that is genetic that
runs in families because lobster boy
whose name was Grady Stiles cuz like I
said we'll get into him later cuz there
was some [ __ ] up [ __ ] going on there
but in that family but he he was the
fifth or sixth generation of his family
that had that not everybody had that
like I cuz I think he had some siblings
that were you know quote-unquote normal
but I think a couple of his siblings had
it as well and he was fifth or sixth
generation and his father had also been
in a sideshow so it's something that
runs in families
right but yeah so another thing that
they do like it more recent ones I guess
to get around [ __ ] this is kind of I
call this the Ed Wood defense where it's
like if you want to make a movie with
like a lot of like Perea type of stuff
in it like you know [ __ ] you know
transvestitism say you know when it
wasn't really that acceptable or you
wanted to put like you know naked women
and or something like that then you
would make the movie but like say that
it was like a document document or like
some kind of moral thing so what they
would start to do when they were trying
to circumvent laws about you know
pickled punks in particular but what
they would do is they'd say Oh we'll
come see the victims of drug abuse
that's what they would call them so it's
like then they wanted to put like kind
of a moralist sort of veneer on it so
that they wouldn't wear helmets right
right it's like it's educational that's
what they were trying to do so I feel
like that's kind of what Ed Wood would
do as well he's like yeah I want to put
like naked ladies and men and women's
clothes in my movie but I don't want it
to seem like trashy or anything if I'm
saying it's British helping America it's
for educational part helping Americans
stopping communism right so I feel like
that's kind of what we're there kind of
which like I said I admired the [ __ ]
grift man I'm
into it it's like if you can come up
with a good enough story to like
separate people from their money than
hey Edna exactly exactly I do a [ __ ]
show on it we should do a whole [ __ ]
show on Ed Wood yeah he's a fascinating
yeah is it it's like and and I love I
wish that one thing about it what is I
wish that he had long lived long enough
to see how kind of beloved he became
because I feel like he he died sort of
in you know he had a drinking problem he
went into porn it's like I wasn't making
any money he wasn't making it yes it has
been washed up right and it that is
never a been actually yeah and there's
it bums me out because especially
nowadays that like everybody knows who
he is and it's like everybody knows who
he is because he made terrible movies
but they were also really entertaining
movies it was a man making something out
of nothing
yeah and that's I kind of respect that I
do as well don't have anything yes I did
make something out of that I think the
thing that I had that's we have a
measure of a man really what do you
think about it yeah you have anything
stop him he's right yeah everybody knows
who Ed Wood is this and like I said
that's I think that's what I had but
that in his enthusiasm yeah you know
what I mean yeah like he just wanted to
make it masterpieces he didn't give a
[ __ ] that he didn't know what he was
doing he didn't give a [ __ ] that he was
just like with all these people that
were like drug addicts and like connect
and although he didn't give a [ __ ] they
didn't have any money to like make real
props or anything like that he's just
like we're gonna do this goddammit and
it's like you have to admire that as you
know is the only in the Ed Wood movie go
see it yeah that's important one that's
probably probably other than Beetlejuice
I think that's my favorite Tim Burton
Burton made it's called Ed Wood yeah
some of you youngsters have never seen
that but that movie is in education it
is yes yeah it's and it's mostly true
it's fairly accurate they didn't change
that much about his story I think you
know what I mean I think he's slightly
different than how Johnny Depp portrayed
him but not that much but you'll see you
know Ed Asner [ __ ] doing Bela Lugosi
a [ __ ] it has her name heartland
martin landau
yeah doing [ __ ] Bela Lugosi yeah
[ __ ] strung out heroin Bela goes
it's [ __ ] awesome hilarious that was
one of the very few movies where I
actually forgot that Bela Lugosi was
dead
yeah and then but I was watching that
movie Bonnie the transsexuals and yeah
Bill Murray played him Billy Murray
played him and the stupid stupid use
your minds can you play an alien playing
an alien and a moot it's just a [ __ ]
funny movie here not a minute in its
plan 9 from outer space it's like it's a
terrible movie but it's one of those
movies that's so terrible that it goes
all the way around it becomes super
awesome again just because it's so
entertaining Ed Wood is the movie that
if you're like us and know been in the
goth scene for a long time you
understand it at a different level yeah
yeah it's a very goth goth scene movie
it is because he was kind of surrounded
by [ __ ] bunch of weirdos and misfits
and that's kind of what the guy seems
like yeah so in the 90s when we were
coming up yeah it's very similar we
could kind of like relate really keep
trying to make some kind of a [ __ ]
living out of something somewhere yeah
yeah and like I said you gotta [ __ ]
admire that and then I and I think that
there's kind of a parallel between what
Ed Wood was doing with moviemaking and
what
sideshow managers really get like it's
all it's all that similar type of it's
all that same thing you're in some kind
of little subculture or [ __ ] unusual
people and you're trying to figure out
how you can make money with this yeah
and that's really how the world works
everybody's doing that you got to find
your own [ __ ] angle man yeah
everybody's doing that at a some level
or another
yes billionaire is doing that especially
nowadays now that you have and in a way
it's like a lot easier nowadays you have
YouTube and you have like all of these
platforms where you don't really need
that much money and you can kind of
invent yourself right as whatever as a
character yes I think it's kind of
happening at all levels I mean you got
billionaires doing this yeah where yeah
they're in a scene of billionaires how
are we gonna make some more money that's
what they're doing like they need any
more there why don't you give me
something yeah they're not really
they're not really qualitatively
different than anybody else more like
just quantitatively different different
yeah and they they're they're human and
they're [ __ ] up and they [ __ ] [ __ ] up
too and [ __ ] up more people you know
well I mean everybody I feel like
everyone most people let's not say
everybody because I'm sure there's some
exceptions but I think most people have
sort of a drive to make something of
themselves yeah of themselves you know
what I mean it's like you want to be you
don't necessarily want to be famous or
anything like that but it's like anybody
got something what they have well you
want something that's gonna live beyond
you whether that's through your children
say or whether your work or through your
work or something like that I feel like
everybody wants that cuz they don't want
to be forgotten you know what I mean
yeah so I kind of feel like most people
are striving for that yeah so I I don't
have any issue that's why you know it's
like I find a lot of you know let's say
youtubers and slowly felt like I find a
lot of them annoying and [ __ ] like that
but it's like they got their own thing
man and it's like if other people want
to watch that and it's like there are
more choices now than ever
yeah I'm amazed with the world that's
what I mean so in a way like I'm not
gonna piss and moan because yeah there's
a lot of [ __ ] out there I don't like but
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there I really
do like to and it's so easy yeah it's so
easy I mean like growing up like us
growing up in the 70s and 80s you kind
of had to take there wasn't a lot of a
choice with yeah with you were given
yeah there was it was hard like to find
other [ __ ] we didn't you know you didn't
have the internet you thought like if
you grew up in like some nowhere place
like you know yeah you didn't know that
there was nobody else that was into the
same [ __ ] as you and it was like a pain
in the ass but it's like now it's like
so easy and I feel like I'm kind of glad
that I'm you know it sucks being old but
it's like I'm kind of glad that I was
born when I was because I can appreciate
we got a foot in both worlds yeah I can
appreciate how much better it is now
that you can pretty much I can turn on
my [ __ ] computer and I can watch
whatever the [ __ ] I want whenever I want
yeah and it's like and you know they're
eating a lot of you youngsters just take
that [ __ ] for granted that's what I mean
so it's like that's why I'm glad it's so
much easier now that's why I'm glad that
it's so much easier to be anything so
much very Austin so much easier to be a
geek it's so much easier to be a
collector yeah back in the day if you
collected something you had to
physically go out and look for it like
you were hunting yeah you weren't gonna
[ __ ] find it yeah there was no eBay
yeah there's no eBay it's just so much
easier now yeah and like and you know
like I said you and me grew up in the
goth scene it's like you know back in
the 80s you could even find clothes yeah
I had a go to like thrift stores and
like my old lady clothes and they like
and make stuff stuff out of it cuz there
was no hot topic we don't have hot topic
we didn't have the internet we know that
right yeah we don't have anything like
that so it's like you had to make your
own [ __ ] and like if you lived in a big
city it was probably better because you
know New York City they had like the big
city the big stores and stuff but it's
like we didn't have that you know where
I grew up and so it it's kind of like
and you go to the record store and you
just depended on what they had yeah and
like you know I could remember oh man
Mississippi 1983 you could go to a
[ __ ] really generic mall called the
sawmill square mall and arel out in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere you look at it
now it's just inconsequential and you
are lucky to get an Iron Maiden album
yeah it's like [ __ ] man the mall record
shows and I work mine I worked in one
for a time but I got fired because I'm
not a people person yeah so but you know
well you know I did you people are dumb
and it's like I wasn't afraid of like
yeah but you know what I mean so I know
what you need to be doing that's what I
mean it's like [ __ ] yeah that's what all
I ever wanted to do I'm just like I
always just want to like I want to write
books I want to make board games I want
to like you know do that kind of [ __ ] I
don't want to have to like interact with
people and sell them things and [ __ ]
like that cuz I don't like people yeah
so if you're if you're at home whining
and crying you don't know how lucky you
have it you got the world your
fingertips you can [ __ ] so easy
everything you can connive and grift
anything yeah now if you've got a
[ __ ] half a brain you can make money
now I mean it's a lot of work I'm not
saying it's not for free because it's
all at your fingertips it has taken me I
mean because for a long time
when I mean I worked a regular job I was
a graphic designer for many years
20-something years and I got laid off in
what 2016 yeah that's why I decided
message any you got to make your move
man and it was hard for a little while
but I mean the fact that I have so many
different things going on which it's
very stressful for me but it's like you
know the fact that I write books the
fact that I design board games the fact
that I do the show the fact that I still
have graphic design clients that I do
like romance stuff for so that can make
up any extra I write I write articles
for paranormal channels I do like all
this kind of stuff I'm gonna take credit
I'm the one I'm the one that gave me the
confidence I said Jenny don't you don't
need them yeah we can do all this
because I hated the job that I'm right
here through the Home Office yeah and it
turned it there was a couple months of
instability maybe like a dry year - yeah
cuz though cuz yeah cuz my mom that
dried up pretty quick that takes time to
make that transition but eventually it
all worked out yeah I mean it's no kind
of touch-and-go it's like I don't have
you know I don't guarantee I make enough
money to pay bills I don't have a lot of
extra um but you know what I mean it's
it's and it's a lot of work a lot of
times like you know I get up at 7:00 or
6:30 or 7:00 or whatever and I work with
all the time I don't have weekends I
don't have vacations I don't have any
choice every day of the week
every single day and usually until 7 or
8 o'clock at night and luckily you know
we got good patrons and it can't it
works out yeah I mean the way I look at
it you're only doing about half or
really what you're worth
yeah it takes time you've already been
independent only for a couple years
that's true and we you you it's gonna
build yeah your books alone are awesome
you know yeah you know yeah
another book needs to come they're
asking for another book I'm probably
gonna do and I'll probably announce okay
L&L sit here right now but um because
this is the thing this was one of the
ideas that I was throwing around and
this seemed like to get the most
traction with people that I asked
since people seem to like the faceless
villain trilogy so much and since it's
2020 you know and since another 20-year
period has gone by like since the end of
the faceless villain 3 so somebody said
why don't you do a fourth one that's
like millennium that's you know like
from 2000 to 2009 teen so that's gonna
be the one episode hopefully I will have
it out by the end of the year we'll see
I haven't really I just started doing
like an outline so it's gonna be new and
active serial killers a lot of times
yeah which hopefully they don't read it
and come and kill me but you know I got
you man okay all right so we're probably
at Way past an hour yes we are so maybe
we should take a break and then we come
back we'll kind of talk about I want to
talk about some kind of individual yeah
we're going to talk about freaks
themselves uh freaks since there's so
many more famous ones some of the ones
that I thought were kind of interesting
and kind of go into that so we'll talk
about that a little bit more when we
come back we will be back in just a few
minutes what you talking about Ms pokey
is there like a buck over there oh yeah
I saw that it was like a little moth I
wonder what you Oh bless you wonder what
you were over there talking about she's
worrying she wishes you like hey hey
there's like a bother
rockers open a spooky language for that
once you knew it oh are you gonna get it
yeah oh my goodness she's like what I'm
not
yeah he's got legs all over the place
lines all over the way you're delightful
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back yeah talking about
all this [ __ ] refreshing drinks and
going to the bathroom and edge caching
cats had to go out and catch the kitty
was attacked by deer a whole herd of
them yeah there was a whole bunch of
deer in the backyard you guys yeah but
well not our backyard but it's like our
backyard kind of like it's a yeah it's a
long it's got a pond and everything
actually I went and checked it it was
actually three feet deep oh [ __ ] I could
see the bottom so alligators could live
in that
well now that's like make okay she's not
allowed to go out Saturday well no I go
out there for some reason she's like the
last few days she just likes to she
doesn't go in it or anything well sits
on that Bank though although I think she
did go in it the other day because she
brought us a wet tennis ball I don't
know where she got it which I'm not sure
if she went out in the water and got it
from that cuz it's not ours initially I
found a bank somehow it was soaking wet
though yeah but she was like oh she was
super proud of it she came up on the
back porch and she's like hey you guys
check it out I brought you this thing
it's like it's round and fuzzy and I
don't know what this it's like she was
like all excited like she would have
always given her little balls yeah she
has lots of toy balls yeah
toy balls now she's a take now she's
[ __ ] she's [ __ ] like yeah she's
[ __ ] with the lighting rig and she's
gonna lighting I tried to improve the
lighting in here and got some
incandescent bulbs got rid of that LED
[ __ ] no overhead light that was [ __ ]
sitting there frying me and the direct
[ __ ] radiation and [ __ ] and tried to
get some classier lighting but man
it's better than it was it's still not
great but we'll see it's kind of like
hard to come because I mean this office
is kind of small it was washing this out
man we look like the undead we had some
people [ __ ] comment God you
[ __ ] look pale well I am pale
but like you know what I mean I have
color that some color but you're not
have some color on me yeah but I think
this is a little bit of an improvement
yeah it looks a little bit better I
think maybe four I think
helped to think of it yeah we went and
bought some new bulbs and like moved
around and I got that light there and I
got a light up there moved around the
light got the umbrella lights the
[ __ ] soft bouncing [ __ ] and we turned
the overhead lights off yeah because
even like the overhead lights were like
way too right yeah I guess this looks I
still look like a ghost but that's just
kind of what I look like so yeah just
got so back to the shell is the whitest
[ __ ] ever alright so as I said
now even though the heyday of your
sideshow type freak shows we're probably
like mid 19th century onward there were
obviously kind of you know things prior
to that and it kind of started in
England at least in the mid 16th century
you first started seeing people with
various disabilities and various
deformities and stuff like that like
touring around and like kind of
displaying themselves for money and
people being interested in seeing that
yeah so one of the very first early
examples from this time period was a
fella named Lazarus Colorado now he had
a parasitic twin who was named Johannes
now even though I'm assuming that at the
time they didn't know what caused this
but he had he basically had a parasitic
twin brother that was like hanging out
of his chest
now I don't think that I mean I don't
think that the twin had a brain or
anything like that like it had a face it
was like a whole body and everything but
it's just kind of hung there it could
open its eyes it could like kind of move
around and stuff but I don't think that
it had its own like personalities or not
sentient right like I don't think that
it was like I said this was a long time
ago there were no photographs of it
although there were a lot of drawings of
him cuz he was quite famous at the time
what he did like the guy didn't talk
like I said the brother didn't talk but
he was like his mouth was always open
and apparently like if you pushed on his
chest like he would move his hands and
his ears and like his lips would move
and stuff but I don't think that he
was like like I said I don't think he
had like a brain stem or anything like
that like nowadays we know that what
causes that that's usually like you know
you're in the womb and you have a twin
and you partially like organs absorb the
other twin if you have to eat or was he
living I don't think so right I don't
think so but apparently so this guy
Lazarus Colorado so he kind of like
figured hey you know why not take the
act on the road because apparently
everyone look at him stuff now when he
wasn't like touring and stuff he was
kind of lucky in the sense that he could
put a cloak over his chest and you
couldn't really see it because it was
just kind of he wasn't like a full sized
person like he was in size he was like
underdeveloped I don't think he was
infant size but he was like child size
okay so he could like put a big cloak
over and like you know you can see him
and stuff but um he apparently like made
a large impression he was like you know
at the card of Charles the first he was
a courtier you know in some in this
house of Stewart or whatever the hell it
was so he was like well known for that
at the time and there like I said there
were some drawings and stuff now what's
kind of interesting is that apparently
he did marry later and he like had a
bunch of kids um you know and they said
oh none of them had that condition but
like I said that's not that weird
because we know what causes that now
that's just like a parasitic twin thing
yeah but one thing that's interesting
about Lazarus in particular with it
later on in his life he actually killed
a man I believe in a duel and was
sentenced to death and he was able to
get off right because he said what I am
what about him he didn't do anything so
it was like you'd be killing him too and
that's not fair well you was a this was
in the like 16th century
well Howard do duels illegal in the 16th
century I don't even know if it was the
duel it might imagine straight-up
murders yeah because duels were legal
here way up until the funders he was
like thinking about that ahead of time
it's like hey I could totally kill a
dude with impunity because then if I get
caught I could just say hey you can't
kill him and get snatched so on a side
note I'm a huge advocate of duel culture
I think dueling would solve a lot of
[ __ ] problems
I just do if two [ __ ] have a
disagreement they want to kill each
other
outside the bounds of society and they
both agree to it so be it
who are we to tell these guys they can't
fight each other to the death well you
have about it if they both they both
agree to it and I want to sign the
contracts write that [ __ ] on I say only
kill that [ __ ] I hate him you
know men didn't why not yeah I mean that
would solve a lot of problems I'm a huge
advocate of doing it's in a man's DNA
okay to fight and and and sometimes you
have to work it out that way not all the
times but sometimes there are certain
guys that have to [ __ ] take it that
far in order to solve something ancient
so much on the plus side there would
probably be a lot less [ __ ] and
exactly less [ __ ] and listen less
public violence less [ __ ] less risk
to the public of people doing drive-bys
and stupid [ __ ] like that you do it the
man's way you publicly declare a duel
yes I hate you if you have like a setup
exactly you said [ __ ] I hate you you
I'm I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you I
challenge you to a duel you better show
up to the duel if you're not your Punk
and I win okay and then you settle it
outside the bounds of society in a
little legal culvert a little little
legal cul-de-sac called a duel and then
they could charge admission you could
charge admission you know televise the
[ __ ] cuz you know people wanted you
could televise the [ __ ] you could say
down this day what's-his-name duels
what's the name of in these two [ __ ]
and they're fighting over this it's like
paper this man yes I'm boxing that and
the winner gets the [ __ ] booted the
prize you know me my prizes you know
might be half half of the [ __ ] half
of the proceeds proceeds you know it's
not this Riley it's it's it's it's every
civilization should have that it's a
very civilized I mean like I said if you
have if both people agree that that's
not gonna do and you get them to like I
said it's got to be all legal they got a
second
accidentally I like you know if if both
people don't agree you can't do it I'm
not because then they'll get consent
yeah if you don't agree if one guy
challenges another's if not all right
then your your upon lose yeah you can't
[ __ ] and complain you know min then the
beef has to be beef is over yeah and you
win yeah that would stop so much [ __ ] I
mean so much crime would vanish yeah
because it could all be solved by the
duel cuz you'd have like a way to go
have a way to get dressing your greed
exactly you say if you're so much in
this and then you but then why didn't
you accept my challenge yeah you know
III gave you the public challenge and
you said no and it would solve so much
[ __ ] it would you know nowadays it would
some guys were abusing it back in the
day I read about it you know and there
were people that were abusing it but
nowadays with social media you don't man
pay-per-view and [ __ ] patreon dueling
culture would work yeah and it would
keep [ __ ] in line there are
some people that can only be kept in
line that way without that without the
possibility of being challenged that you
run amok yeah yeah this has been dueling
culture okay like I said I don't even
know if it was a duel or not but he did
kill a guy apparently in like that's how
he got off by saying hey you can't kill
this guy too and he's so like I said I
don't know if he was like thinking about
that ahead of time I was like he's kind
of a genius
alright so another kind of popular guy
that went around like you know kind of
displaying himself were on the Simons
this was like in the 18th century very
famous guy called Mathias booking er
booking her I guess is like the German
way of saying it
sometimes he called Matthew bucking ER
because english-speaking people we can't
be bothered to learn to pronounce
anything in German so he was actually he
was a guy and he was born he didn't have
hands or feet he just had these little
kind of fin like appendages
and he only so he only ended up being
about 29 inches tall now the interesting
thing about this guy was not only he
wasn't only just like going around
touring it's like hey look I'm you know
I was born deformed or whatever but he
can also do a bunch of like really cool
[ __ ] like he he could he was like a
really good marksman he could play
several musical instruments he also did
something that they call micrography I
guess is how you pronounce it it's like
where you make little illustrations but
the illustrations if you like look at
them through like a microscope or
something like that they're all done
with like text like he did this tiny
tiny tiny little touch like he would he
did like a self-portrait and he had like
this wig with like all this curly hair
on his stuff and that if you looked at
pair of microscope it was all like
biblical verses yeah that like made up
yeah and I feel like just recently I
think a museum actually had as awesome
like a thing of his work and everything
like that because it was like really
amazing look there was another form of
art from the 1700s a lot of people
forgotten about it was a painting look
like a circle and if he just looked at
it it looked like a damn swirl a swirl
of colors but if you put a highly
polished cylinder in the middle of it
like a [ __ ] cylindrical mirror you
could look into that cylinder and the
reflection of that colored swirl would
give you a painting it yeah and 60
degrees yeah where when you looked
around it you could see and dudes are
doing that by hand mhm
that's how much time a white boy [ __ ]
had on his head that's what I mean they
did like a lot of that kind of like
painting is that yeah you can look into
the cylinder and walk around it and look
down into it you need to get a 360
panoramic painting of some [ __ ] yeah
some people making out in a damn park or
something here and there white wigs on
and everything I did an amazing [ __ ]
back I've seen ones that were I've never
seen one like that but I've seen some
that had that had stuff at the bottom
that like if you look if you tilted the
painting like that or if you looked at
it like
like you couldn't see it like just
looking at it straight on but if you
looked at it from an angle or if you set
it up then it was like a skull and [ __ ]
like that I've seen ones like that it
was like a lot of optical effects like
they were dealing with a lot of computer
that computers in the internet are a
great thing man but I'll tell you what
it is sapping away human potential there
people without it hundreds of years to
do hundreds of years ago we're doing
amazing feats of [ __ ] mental
gymnastics yeah the people you had said
are a long forgotten yeah
just long forgotten [ __ ] that they could
do painting things in extremely small
yeah doing things like like the 360
panagra panoramic [ __ ] reflections
weird [ __ ] like some shadow dune yeah
yeah well like you said they have like a
lot more time back then and I think like
a lot of stuff was new so there was like
a lot of stuff where people were like
experimenting yeah with various things
because they didn't really know like
with the potential of certain mediums
weren't as weird as this is
pre-industrial revolution yeah they were
doing all that yeah but yeah this guy in
particular who was called the little man
from Nuremberg and I have a couple
drawings of him too it's like he was he
was like like I said he didn't have any
arms or legs so he was just kind of like
he was just kind of like a little torso
and ahead and but they have like
drawings of him and stuff like with the
powdered wig and like the little outfit
and everything like that like sitting on
a pedestal and yeah he could do all the
stuff he could do magic tricks he built
ships in bottles even though he didn't
have any hands he had like little little
appendages but they were like little
fins he didn't even or anything like
that and he did having legs he shitman
about yeah he could make a ship in a
bottle
must have little rods and stuff that you
used I think he did yeah I don't know if
he used his mouth or if he just used
because I have seen some people that
were born without arms that had like a
little bit of an appendage that learn to
use various rods and you could like
manipulate when there's a will there's a
way
well in the thing too is that a lot of
people that were born like that I mean
no need if they don't know any different
so it's like they just learn to do stuff
the way they have to do it it's like
they never had
arms so it's like I mean they obviously
they know that other people have arms
and it probably makes life easier but
they even ever had them so it's like not
something that they're you know nothing
they're not concerned about it but I'm
just saying it's like well they got a do
[ __ ] the way they gotta do [ __ ] right
and they don't know any other ways so
it's not I mean it'd be different if you
lost your arms later like after you had
had them for a long time then it would
be a bigger pain in the ass but I feel
like if you were born like that
you don't know you wouldn't know any
difference to develop in the body so it
wouldn't be that as big a deal as if you
lost them later on but yeah so the funny
thing about this about this dude was
that apparently he was quite the
man-whore
he was married four times had at least
fourteen children by eight different
women and is rumored to have had
children by as many as 70 different
mistresses so he got around yeah in fact
in the 1780s in England for a time a
woman's vagina was known as buckin hers
boot wasn't good because I guess the
only limb that he had was his dick right
yeah so it's like that was kind of like
he was put in the limb and that was what
they called it and that's like how
widespread his fame was right as a how
it just goes to show you that it's not
really what you look like it's your
status in society that's your games your
game you don't have me or he didn't have
any legs either did he
no just like I said he was just he was
essentially to the torso and a horse OH
- hey with a dick yeah talk to mean game
he did well and he was really talented
he could do a lot of different stuff
like I said he could do magic tricks he
could see he was like a really good like
Roy Martin marksman I think he'd use
like a bow and arrow he could like shoot
guns he could do all that kind of stuff
that so it's so like I said like you
said yes you know how you look is
important you know if you're pretty
things are very much easier for you but
it just goes to show that you can
overcome that you can overcome almost
anything with enough determination
well he was probably had a [ __ ] very
high level of charisma I'm yeah you know
and I would imagine money helps too he
could probably provide security yeah
I mean look there are a little clay
statues buried in the ground and [ __ ]
Egypt ancient Egypt of I guess dwarves
guys with Dwarfs being pictured with
full-sized women and near royal burials
in ancient Egypt yeah these are very
successful guys so that didn't hold him
it didn't hold them back yeah but I
guess they were you know working on
construction and businessmen you know
didn't matter yeah a civilized society
looks at a man very differently than say
like a primitive society you know I mean
where it's a hunt you know like a
hundred gatherer of society where you
have to have physical prowess and in a
civilized society woman one that's very
developed a man can make his way on
mentality and character alone yeah you
know I mean well I always felt like the
and and this kind of ties into the whole
you know freakshow thing is that you
really kind of have to take what you're
given and lean into it take things that
maybe other people would see as a
disadvantage you gotta flip that and use
it to your advantage
Oscar Wilde said if you got skeletons in
your closet you better learn how to make
them dance yeah and that's a very good
advice for life I think yeah and here's
something interesting too I believe one
of the one of the very early famous you
know freaks quote-unquote was a
three-legged man I think believe his
name was Franklin teenie Lentini and he
actually had a fully formed leg like
that was kind of coming out the back and
the knee had like a foot growing out of
it he also I believe he also had two
fully functioning penises damn now he
said that when he was I mean he was born
like that obviously and he said when he
was a kid it really bothered him
obviously because a lot of kids made fun
of him
you know as they would his kids suck but
um but he said when he was seven or
eight years old he got taken to like a
hospital where there were like a lot of
other disabled children and he said I
saw kids there that were blind or deaf
or something like that and I realized
that they were a lot worse off than me
it's like I just had an extra leg it's
like yeah it sucked in people laughed at
me and stuff like that but he's like he
even at that young age he said I'm never
gonna feel sorry for myself ever again
because there are people in the world
like way worse off than I am so he
decided that he was just gonna use that
to his advantage and later on he became
actually one of the best known and like
highest-paid you know sideshow
performers like he could kick a soccer
ball like with the extra leg and he
could do all this stuff with it so he
kind of had a really good attitude about
it even though it had bothered him as a
child you know what I mean so I think
that's kind of like a good way of
looking at looking you know even if you
don't have a disability like that or
anything like that I think it's you know
I always try to kind of think of how
much worse off you know it could be you
know and so and I think that might be
some of the appeal of like freak shows
as well is that people are going and
seeing you know say you know the one the
one woman that was bills like the
mule-faced woman she was actually at
first she was billed as the ugliest
woman in the world which that's kind of
terrible she's like can we just please
call me something else that's like
that's kind of mean but it's like so
they ended up calling her the mule-faced
woman and she you know was on tour for a
long time but you know it's like what
else are you gonna do it's like this is
like there's nothing you can do about it
and it's like I feel like people that
are coming and seeing those people are
like it's kind of terrible but you're
thinking well you know maybe I'm not the
the most beautiful person in the world
but I'm not that person I think a lot of
it had to do with regular people coming
to this is a long time ago yeah you know
it's a very different society you had
people coming to see these freaks and in
a way it was an opportunity to normalize
it yeah okay yeah to kind of educate the
the average common
okay I want to put it to that these are
people yeah and just because they look
this way you know I mean they're not
monsters yeah you can though they can
entertain you from their differences
yeah and they're still people
and you should you should really kind of
like thank your lucky stars that you
weren't born with that yeah you know I
mean that's another way to look at it
too so I actually kind of think
ultimately in the end the freak show was
a benefit to mankind I think it was as
well because it was it like I said it
gave people an understanding because she
would it was you because you could
interact with somebody that had that
particular disability and they could
talk to you and answer your question
I'll just know well this is just a purse
it's just a person just like anyone else
over time mankind outgrew the need for
it yeah but it sure the hell a lot
better than other civilizations they
would throw rocks and stone people like
this to death or just kill them kill
them on sight because they thought they
were because I've demonic army
yeah which which is something that had
been done like prior right so I feel
like it probably wasn't until like kind
of you know the Age of Enlightenment or
whatever we're people you know where
people stopped seeing these people is
like cursed cursed or demonic or
something like that and started seeing
them in a more medical yeah type of you
know light there was a possibility that
anyone could be born that way right so I
think in that way it's like as you know
as tacky or as trashy or something like
that as people maybe want to perceive it
it was still a phase I think yeah I
think in a way it it gave us a long term
benefit people who just happened to be
born with particular yeah now we know
what it is it's not an oddity yeah you
have to show it to anybody we have mass
media and we have an education system
well it in a way we so we still have an
equivalent of that because they still
have TV shows that have yeah that have
there's at you know my 600-pound life we
have like TV shows about like you know
conjoined twins and you guys [ __ ]
Beetlejuice on on on Howard Stern right
so people are still interested in it
they're just people but it's just I
think people nowadays understand those
are just people that were born that way
and it's like they're not any different
than anyone else
and you know [ __ ] I I grew up [ __ ]
watching Howard Stern listen to and beat
you know I care about B yeah you know
they call him beat you know you can you
can see beat and [ __ ] follow The
Adventures of beetlejuice on youtube
today
yeah he's still around yeah I thought he
was yeah he's still right
yeah the old things the old days they
used to [ __ ] do things with
beetlejuice elevated yeah go on
adventures with him and adventure yeah
yeah yeah sending places you know send
him among among among the stars and
Claudia cutter Rd and [ __ ] just funny
funny things you could do a beat yeah
yeah and like I said you know as I was
saying before yeah there's a fine line
between like exploitation and blah blah
blah but it's like in a lot of ways I
feel like as long as they kind of have
some idea of what they're in for what
they're doing I don't really I don't see
a lot of problem with it as long as
everyone involved like kind of knows
what's going on and stuff and I should
say too I wanted to mention this as well
because this is something that I didn't
know until today and I just kind of
stumbled across a an interesting article
about this is that sort of indirectly
the whole sideshow World's Fair kind of
thing might have been responsible for
helping premature infants because check
this out
so the widespread use of an ink of an
incubator for you know babies that are
born prematurely this actually came
about because of a German man whose name
was Martin Cooney or County I guess um I
don't know like he was called the doctor
I don't know if he was like technically
a doctor like I don't know if he
finished medical school or not but
apparently his own daughter had been
born prematurely and so this was
something that was like very interesting
to him that he was like trying to save
babies that were born too early so he
kind of got into you know making
incubators are trying to make incubators
like a more widespread thing and back in
the day like the medical community were
not really all that into they're like
well if they're born too early so
nothing we can do about
it's just kind of like [ __ ] happens and
they weren't really they didn't think
incubators were gonna work or it just
wasn't feasible or whatever for whatever
reason so this particular guy was like
well you know what if the medical
establishment isn't gonna listen to me
about incubators I'm gonna take this
[ __ ] like on the road so what he did was
he essentially made incubators full of
premature babies like almost like a
sideshow exhibit like at sideshows and
stuff like in the World's Fair and
things so he would have like the a tent
and it would have like all these
incubators it with preemies in them and
like nurses and stuff and then people
would pay to come in and see these teeny
teeny little babies and the incubators
and then he would use the money to like
help the babies right here and he ended
up saving like thousands and thousands
of premature Bertha probably would have
died without his intervention and
because of his kind of Fame and you know
how well-known this kind of show became
that he kind of toured with eventually
the medical establishment was like oh
maybe incubators are worth looking at
welcome and it kind of became like a
more widespread thing so in a way like
that seemed like a really positive
development room that because he
couldn't get any traction like in the
you know mainstream medical
establishment he's like well I'm just
gonna take this to the public during
like the public like in the World's Fair
that's an angle and that ended up
working really well because people would
apparently pay a lot of money to see
teeny little babies and incubators and
it ended up like helping them and saving
them when maybe they would have died
otherwise so I thought that was kind of
like an interesting sort of thing which
I didn't actually even know about until
today so fun fact now so as cool as some
products of the Freak Show were there
was of course a dark side and in that
vein let's talk about Sarah Baartman
more popularly known as the Hottentot
Venus Hottentot Venus yeah what is a
Hottentot um it was kind of like a term
that they used for a particular type of
African okay person what does that mean
so okay so this is what ended up
happening with this unfortunate yeah
she actually ended up she was born
around 1789 in South Africa and she was
in a tribe called the Khoikhoi okay now
she was actually um she was brought up
on a farm like her parents were probably
servants her mother died when she was
just a toddler her father died when she
was a teenager she ended up marrying a
guy from the tribe and they had a baby
but he died later on now as the Dutch
expanded their colonialism into South
Africa they started kind of taking a lot
of the locals as slaves and whatnot so
um when apparently when Sarah was 16
years old her fiance was murdered by
Dutch colonists and then shortly after
that she was actually sold into slavery
to a trader who was named Peter William
say czar now he took her to Cape Town
where she became like a maid at a at the
guys brother's house and after this they
apparently made her sign a contract with
a guy who was a he was English and he
was a ship surgeon and his name was
William Dunlop now he was a friend of
the guy that he had quote-unquote bought
her from and he said that he wanted to
take her to England and Ireland and he
wanted her not only to work as like a
maid or a domestic servant but he also
wanted to be able to exhibit her for
entertainment purposes because Sarah had
very unusually large buttocks what damn
and not just and they were kind of like
and like shaped kind of strange
like what um got a pitch rub um there's
a drawing there's a drawing and there's
drawings of her okay so she was
apparently came off as like very exotic
right because of the you know odd
proportions I guess right yeah buttocks
so they there was a booty mania going on
yeah back in the well yeah they don't
know about it yeah it's like I said it
wasn't
just it it wasn't just a big it wasn't
just a big ass it was like it was like a
very strange it was kind of like shaped
like I don't even know like how to
because there's men in the audience we
got to know what it is Ange Lee it's a
very strangely shaped buttocks well
strange that could be me which I was a
diamond the shape we talk about
strawberries are we talking about like
hexagons what are we talking about here
Oh triangular it kind of like it kind of
like went up yeah I don't want to say
like to a point okay but it was kind of
like went up boon and then back down
booty went up to a point
sort of yeah it was according to the
drawings like I said there's no
photographs of her really because I was
too long ago okay but the drawings of
her it had a booty that you could see
from the front pretty much okay so yes
so that was like why so essentially they
took this woman and they said that she
signed this contract even though she was
illiterate and didn't know what it said
and everything like that um so they take
her from her home in South Africa and
they take her to England and they
essentially put her in indentured
servitude for five years that's what the
contract said so yes she also apparently
had some like her skin coloring was like
unusual so that was another thing well I
don't know why I said that like the
drawing I couldn't really tell right so
so basically this guy is like well we
want to take her to London and like put
her on display and in a freak show like
they wanted to put her on that's a
[ __ ] amazing that a woman's booty
could be so extreme then it goes into a
freak show well and you have to imagine
these are like also white dudes and also
like a lot of the African yeah how weird
was this [ __ ]
it was very well know like I said what
she took shape is very weird it's weird
it's not like a normal but it's not just
like oh she's got a big like you know a
big booty drawing yeah it was just it
was very weirdly like shaped to like
it's stuck out really far and it was
like not like butt shaped it was like
you know what everybody no it was just
like it kind
team up to a point a little bit but not
a point point yeah so I mean I'm trying
to imagine it's just it was very strange
looking so I feel like that was one
thing that like made okay like her drug
like you know attention drawn to her
okay so they wanted to take her
apparently there was this um you know in
Piccadilly there was a building where
they would you know display like human
oddities I guess you want to call it um
you know they they had like [ __ ] they
back in the day it's like they didn't
really have any compunction at all about
like just calling humans as like the
ugliest birds in the world it's like the
greatest deformity ever and it's like so
it's they had all that kind of [ __ ] so
that's where they wanted to put her so
they put her on display and she was
essentially like mostly naked they would
just like kind of cover up like little
bits of her but mostly she was like
naked because I guess you could do that
in the sense that you know like back in
the black and back of the National
Geographic it white people BBS and it
was National Geographic if they were
like Africans yeah and it was fine you
didn't know the boobs yeah Jack I always
thought was like [ __ ] back in this
Jewish back in the day there are many a
young white boy introduced to the
[ __ ] female anatomy through damn
National Geographic and that's not just
me saying this everybody knows about it
that's right well that's yeah that's why
I'm like I showed Nick I knew you were
gonna say that yeah they showed a go-bag
with no problem but [ __ ] didn't make it
white women have to put you couldn't
show me you had a like you had a like
pixel it up or put a ball right it
wasn't on purpose they were just showing
tribal people and then wanted people see
what what tribal life was like yeah yeah
it's very handy but they would allow
that but they wouldn't allow [ __ ]
white people
you can't show like white tits yeah no
but it's like oh we can show these well
waiting we're looking at it is this
thing they were trying to show tribal
wife you know crazy so that's way tribal
people looked yeah it's like they didn't
wear shirts like they you ain't wearing
clothes so our very little clothes or
door you know
they weren't making cloth yeah you know
so it was understandable so yes so I
feel like that was this kind of
situation where had she been a white
European I don't think they would have
gotten away with showing her almost
completely naked like on stage but
because she is African it was fine yeah
and also I mean the shitty thing - it's
like so when they brought her to London
like they did they were able to be like
put her on display and stuff but because
there was like a lot of like
anti-slavery like campaigning going on
at the time so obviously there are a lot
of people like kind of asking questions
about how she was being treated and
stuff so the guys who were displaying
her actually did get brought to trial
but were acquitted like they got away
with it so they apparently at the trial
they kind of brought forth this document
that they said oh well Sarah signed this
and it says that she's totally fine with
it even though like I said she was
illiterate saffron well you was it was
late seventeen hundreds yeah yeah a long
time though yeah so however because of
like the kind of brouhaha about it she
did actually they did you know try to
give her like better conditions like
better clothes and things like that
now she was actually in London for four
years in September of 1814 she got taken
to France and sold to a guy named ro I
guess do you know what I mean that's I
don't remember a lot of my French but I
think that's how you pronounce his name
now he was a guy that had like a
traveling like exotic animal show so he
exhibits Sarah in Paris and he put her
on display in a cage with a baby
rhinoceros Danny and they had a trainer
and he talked to her like she was an
animal like telling her like to stand up
and sit down like trained like he would
be with the animals so yeah and all she
was wearing was a loincloth I can
picture that that goes but they're
trying to make a wild man act pretty
much like hey look at this exotic woman
right she's wild yes yeah yeah
why from the wild gotta ask just [ __ ]
for days yeah yeah it's okay they put
her in a cage with the right caller
eclipsed she walked by blocks out the
Sun she really had no [ __ ] idea was
gonna does actually doesn't look is
going on what am I doing here why am i
in the cage with a rhinoceros what are
they talking
that's like her entire mindset like
going like what the [ __ ] is like I
understand it would understand that
mankind was a young race at that time
we're terrible we're still terrible but
we're like way more back in those days
back in those days
first of all you had dudes trying to
make money on investment okay
and there was no television or an
awareness or an education 1700s the
average person was pretty [ __ ] dumb
yeah so you know and the guys wanted to
make money and this was the way you
could do it it's weird
there's some crazy [ __ ] like I said I'm
I'm all for like yeah um you know the
freak shows in the sense with with a new
one where people knew like they put
themselves on display and then there was
like a good thing and like humanizing
them and stuff yeah but this kind of
[ __ ] were like these like white
Europeans we're going in Africa and you
like take a snatchy chicken random
people off yes booty we are them and
putting them in a cage and [ __ ] like
that is like yeah that's not good by
anyone's measure enough you know what I
mean there because there's no consent
but all of them yeah and even back in
the day they were turn to stop it so you
knew that like this was like the early
1800s even then people like noggin we
know can we not she's like a person
still so what are you doing so at least
in my show a friend of the show um girl
she's a mixed background she was talking
about how what she mentioned you know
because on some of the stuff that we
were talking about earlier on with like
that Marie Laveau yeah about how people
she mentioned what was up you know
people hate their slaves now they didn't
I don't think they did it was just
another time people had a limited
awareness
people did have an awareness yeah even
even deer in the Malheur the the real
evoke case when those slaves were
starved they were put on display as a
[ __ ] bad example like look at what
these people did to these yeah even then
that was a bridge too far yeah you even
know a lot of them own slaves right well
yeah there's a bunch of different ways
to look at it
slave owners some of these slave owners
thought that they were doing a good
thing yeah because they were buying
people out of a slave market and they
were saying well I'm gonna take this
person they'll work for me and I'll take
care of them
so it was a better conditions than they
were in yeah and then a lot of them
ended up freeing them but if you can
read about what Jefferson said Jefferson
said I would I would free any slave who
asked for it but I had to let them know
that every sleeves every slave I freed
you usually came to a bad end because
they were in a hostile environment at
that time that was like the shitty thing
is kind of like damned if you do and
damned royal it's like what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do it's like you don't want to
be a slave but then like it's that free
you didn't live as long then because you
know a wild ass environment that's what
I mean that is a shitty situation they
usually died involved in some kind of
[ __ ] starvation or [ __ ] crime and
shootings man it was wild back then
because I mean it was the Wild West well
and there wasn't a lot of opportunity no
jobs there it's kind of like that's kind
of the shitty thing it's like I'm not
saying slavery was good obviously it's
not but it was liable this my [ __ ] was
in back then right and it's like once
they got to a point where the slaves
could be freed and that's awesome
because they you know they weren't a you
know indebted to anyone anymore they
didn't have to like you know run live
that life but it's like I don't think
that society had progressed to the point
where they could just like live like a
normal person because there was just
like that big gap but when we think of
the United States the average person
thinks of the United States of today
that's not the
the United States was in the 1800s at
all yeah big difference I mean there
wasn't the military to speak of there
were no cops the courts were a [ __ ]
joke the federal government couldn't
reach very far outside the [ __ ]
Washington DC you could pass a law
nothing would happen
corporations were more powerful than the
United States at that time and it was
just it was a [ __ ] dangerous place it
was basically [ __ ] lawless Indians
ran this continent basically they were
the ones that were winning for a [ __ ]
long long time
yeah it wasn't until you had trains and
cars really that the United States that
you know starting to appear yeah and
really the United States that we are
living in today is a product of
post-world War two yeah before that time
man you wouldn't recognize this place no
you know there were a bunch of Jeremiah
Johnson [ __ ] around in here
yeah it was a lot different like like I
said what people think of as you know
America the United States like you said
that is very much that's new active yeah
post-war right reconstruction I guess
you know yeah and reconstruction was bad
yeah but yeah so this poor woman so
she's on display in France and I guess
she got famous enough that she attracted
the attention of the very famous
naturalist George cubie a so-so QB a
asks her quote-unquote owner it's like
hey can I study her as a scientific
specimen and he said sure go right ahead
so they had like all these anonymous
like zoologist and [ __ ] like that like
come and study her and they determined
as they would and in the early [ __ ]
1800s that she was the link between
humans and animals yeah because of
course that's what they would have said
[ __ ] have tried to make money
well he also had to understand the
science of the time it was the beginning
of yeah well science the society miss
bunny rabbits science not really science
well kinda there was debate thought it
was it was the very beginnings of they
tried it was the very beginnings of
[ __ ] Darwinism and evolution and
there well this is like quite a bit
wider there for that but yeah the idea
is that Darwin talked about were around
for [ __ ] centuries well even over
millennium Erasmus Dermot Dunn was
talking about that like a generation or
two before and there were stuff that was
being being written about even during
the Roman period yeah that was real
close to kind of well it Armour woods
when you when you observe nature it's a
pretty obvious but you know conclusion
to come to the general kind of idea is
is that humans evolved humans evolved
from animals and they kind of came from
Africa and therefore white people came
from Africans
so therefore Africans were more
animalistic than what you Apple that was
the general understand have even though
it's wrong you can understand how they
well they still not as I say that even
to this day I have black people say well
were the original man I've heard these
hotep [ __ ] and damn [ __ ] you
know I've thought about well that is no
way konna but well well there was
genetic there was genetic drift yeah and
things you know that means so black
people are not primitive black people
are modern well they're just like
they're about the same age as us like I
said what I mean different white skin
just came about because of environmental
environmental reasons there's no
difference between us otherwise that was
just like an environmental you know
depending on what part of the races all
races have their own attributes and
they're all right they're all kind of
tuned to the continent in which they
evolved from but to say that black
people are more primitive than white
people in Asia
kind of inaccurate that is we're all
kind of specialized for the continent
that we evolved in although that becomes
Leonard's common ancestry between us so
that we know it was less important as
global travel as much so it doesn't
really matter as much any an engineer
you're doing what you dealing with
[ __ ] interbreeding is another thing
that happens people get all upset about
this [ __ ] okay but you do genetic tests
on African Americans there's a lot of
[ __ ] European ancestry in well like
like we said not thus everyone was
[ __ ] everybody was [ __ ] everybody
over time and everybody has kind of like
a mixed ancestry to a certain extent I
sure what's that I do for sure yeah and
here's nothing is is that that's
beneficial it is it's beneficial in
general the more genetic diversity you
have in a population the better right it
helps you with resistance to the disease
and health with strength it helps with
beauty you do not want interbreeding
it's just obvious yes over and over
again so genetically the closer the [ __ ]
is it's like that's bad news that's bad
news but then there's all kinds of weird
[ __ ] that people within a race might be
more jet genetically diverse than people
outside generally they are you so what
I'm saying well getting back to
sometimes I'm gonna break it down to a
layman's ability sometimes the
difference between two white people is
more than the difference between a white
person and a black person which that
might tell us somebody's mind but I
might have more in common with another
with a black person than I do with
another white person yeah it just
depends on what like I said there's
really no way of knowing unless you do
like Josh knows everybody because in a
lot of ways I have read somewhere and I
did you know I don't have the exact
numbers so forgive me but I have read
somewhere that if you wiped out
everybody on earth except for like you
know people in Africa saying it's like
you would still have like 99% of the
genetic diversity yeah you can make a
white person out of the genes that exist
in Africa yeah that's what happened yeah
that's what I mean no it's just like an
environmental factor it's just there are
like a random mutation there are F
in races there are as white as me and
that have straight hair and that have
colored eyes all of that came from
Africa yeah that's what I mean edit it
all I think that really Africa is the
most genetically do yes from that
continent there's enough genes there to
make all the race makeup yeah all the
race because that's what happened that's
where it came from all that traveling
through the continents sucking weeded
out certain features and you ended up
with white people in Oriental or Asian
people yeah and then then there's a
bunch of trade in between them the black
people back in Africa were also modified
by what was happening in Europe and the
middle yeah like I said they're East so
there was a lot of trade you always
screwin people who are your neighbors
well there's a lot of neighbors it
traces all the way back in Africa yeah
so the people that are in Africa today
are not ancient africans their modern
Africans affected by what's been
happening in the rest of the world it's
called genetic drift well yeah and like
I said they they've had I mean for
thousands of years they've had like you
know a lot of trade routes and things
like that so it so populations are not
as isolated as they used to be as well
and not as isolated even back then as
people thought they were yeah there was
a lot of
interbreeding and simply Africans spread
out everywhere all these little islands
going all the way as far as like Munim
[ __ ] out in at an Easter Island
actually there seems to be changed which
is off the coast of Chile yeah which is
there seems to been Africans there even
though that they were a weird mixture of
African and Caucasian which is race is
the [ __ ] funny ass thing it's weird
and it's all temporary it's constantly
changing yeah so you can't get too hung
up in race it's it's just a temporary
status I always kind of approached it
the way you know like black cats and
white cats and grey cats and brown
calves they're all they're all cats yeah
and it's like they're not fighting
whistles like all the gray caps over
here and all the white cats over there
and it's like it's measurements
worried about it so yeah so poor Sara
Baartman like I said so she gets not
only she being kept in a cage with the
rhinoceros but now she has like a whole
bunch of like zoologists and [ __ ] like
that like trying to like study her yeah
and like you know saying oh yes we have
the missing link between humans and
animals and also she's probably like oh
goody I wish I knew what they were
saying because it sounds really [ __ ]
II now the sad thing about it is that
Sara Baartman actually ended up dying at
the age of 26 years old no one is
entirely sure what she died of it might
have been pneumonia or it might have
been smallpox some people have also
thought that it might be alcoholism
maybe she drank a lot I can't blame the
sister I'm just saying right yeah
because she wasn't in a good situation
strong I'm just gonna drink his [ __ ]
this [ __ ] was just 1700s early 1880s
yeah
now the sad thing was after she died she
merely [ __ ] dignity after she died
man so after she died
George qva gets her remains and
dissected her made a plaster cast of her
body pickled her brain and genitals and
put them into jars which were put on
display in a museum in the 1970s so they
were convinced she was another species
basically it seemed like that's what I
mean it's like this and this holiday she
would have been a porn star probably
from back in those days that we got a we
got a face they treated it like an
animal yeah we're gonna have to [ __ ]
categorize we're gonna have to [ __ ]
put this into [ __ ] and it's like it's
it bothers me so much because like look
I'm like I'm a science dork and I'm very
into like a whole Age of Enlightenment
thing and like you know scientific but
it does seem to me that in a lot of ways
the early you know the the very early
years of like the scientific method and
things like that they meant well
yeah dude work out but it kind of came
across like you end up treating people
as though they were like a like a weird
specimen that you could like and they
kind of forgot that this was a human
being
well it's a very immature mistake it is
and it seems like an easy mistake to
avoid but it happened a lot yeah so I
feel like that that's kind of like the
dark side like I said if like the early
sideshow culture is that you know as
much as it was kind of empowering I
guess for people that have like
disabilities and stuff that otherwise
might have you know like you said been a
burden on their family or like not have
you know had a normal life I do feel
like there was an element of oh let's go
to like Africa and like kidnap like
exotic looking people and then like put
them in cages find the mission I was
like you said is like a missing link or
a wild man or something or what is it
that was another common thing that they
would do if they couldn't like identify
you so I feel like there was like a
really big aspect of like kind of racism
and kind of that kind of thing going on
- just because white Europeans white
Americans they're not used to seeing
now when you say racist and racism and
the racists in a way racism was a part
of science there was actually a group of
guys called racist I know that studied
race and race and culture nowadays you
called cultural anthropologists but
later on you know I mean that guy there
was a big stigma between about those
guys and they become racists but
originally they would be called the
cultural anthropologists they wrote
books about it trying to figure out what
race came from what yeah how certain
cultures evolved you know which like I
said there's there's nothing wrong with
that because I mean obviously there are
you know people have differences they
were just studying the differences
between people and you know as far as
long as that's how it goes I and the
problem arises is that you know you can
take that and some people kind of ran
with that in the sense it's like oh this
one's more evolved than the other ones
more better than the other one or
something which is not the case because
no one's more evolved than anyone
because we've all been around the same
amount of time like the human race has
been around the same road so no one's
more evolved argument they were doing is
that people evolved in different
yeah I know some of the directions they
wanted to go in the other direction is
that they didn't yeah
which that goes all the way back to HG
Wells the Socialists and you know I mean
so I can understand where they're coming
from they're like you can understand
where they got those idea right they're
trying the original so-called racists
we're very close to the Communists and
the Socialists they were trying to
evolve mankind towards progression right
we're progressiveness you know I mean
which which yeah and it's like that's
not a bad thing it's like to want to
better everyone relation but you have to
like you know you have to watch where
you're unintended consequences are gonna
go yeah you know what I mean so yeah so
afters poor woman died so that so there
has been like a [ __ ] almost a century
long campaign for South Africa to get
this poor woman's remains back to South
Africa they didn't go back there until
2002 they finally got her remains back
and gave her like a proper burial all
over it all over some magnificent booty
crazy I feel so bad right but like I
said it as a whole I'm like I'm like an
advocate of like you know freakshow
culture in the sense of like people like
that actually worth it actually wanted
to do it yeah but it's like you know you
just like are living your life like in a
village somewhere there's somebody
giraffe that goes oh look at your booty
I'm just like let's ago when they sell
you into [ __ ] Europe and you don't
even speak the language you're like
what's going on you know what I mean and
then they put you in a cage with a brain
next to a rhino and then she died so
young yeah that one was in a nightmare
man that [ __ ] that's what I mean so
that's like kind of like the dark side
of like you know freakshow culture like
I said it had that's not an unusual case
that's what I mean she's just the most
famous yeah that's not that's not that
unusual I mean [ __ ] in that era the
[ __ ] they did the children this you know
the mean [ __ ] they had little [ __ ]
society back in the [ __ ] early 1800
what the [ __ ] they Rosario the [ __ ] they
were doing had little kids dinner damn
[ __ ] coal mines dick hey Jed yeah if
I can just did all problem with that no
see those people lived people live fast
and they died young but they didn't have
any it's almost like they didn't have
any concept of like human empathy yeah I
mean I mean they did because empathy is
a very normal thing like it's you even
see in the animal kingdom some people
were like climate this can't be right
but yes not the way that it actually
worked out there they were there were a
weird people I mean like I said we were
talking about before like it seems like
you know prior to you know the 20th
century I feel like they didn't even see
children as children they're just like
as soon as you were old enough to work
you went to work you were just like a
little bitty adult they [ __ ] raped
little children and didn't think
anything of it I don't think they
thought anything of it and like I said
the sad thing about like a lot of people
that ended up in you know freak shows
are human oddities shows a lot of them
ended up there and they were very little
and stuff like that but the reason they
ended up there is because their parents
abandoned them or their parents sold
them yeah two freaks in like when they
were little like here take them I don't
know what to do with this honey here
because they have a deformity or
something so they sold them to it so
their parents like would do that so like
I said in a way it's you know that sucks
obviously because your parents [ __ ]
sold you to strangers but in some ways
it turned out okay because you know they
they actually had a life and they have
money and they ended up having a normal
life and friends and everything so it
turned out all right but the fact that
that was a thing that you could do and
no one really like thought that much
about it that's kind of [ __ ] up yeah
felt like parents were willing to like
[ __ ] sell their [ __ ] children into
yeah essentially slavery business so
another very famous pair of
quote-unquote freaks were obviously
Chang and Eng yeah the original Siamese
twins yeah that's weird because they
were from Thailand
yeah which used to be called Siam sorry
it's funny how a whole condition was
named
damn country like science Siamese twins
like those twins because they well
that's how like [ __ ] famous they were
and honestly the thing about Chang and
Eng was that nowadays if they were born
nowadays they were only joined by like
kind of a tube of flesh like on their
abdomen so it was very easy to separate
them nowadays but back then they
couldn't because they were born in 1811
so they really didn't have a lot of
choice I feel like they were kind of
reluctant to want to display themselves
like in sideshows and stuff but after a
while they were kind of like okay
whatever they kind of like felt like
that was kind of the only thing they
could do sort of so they kind of did
that so I feel like so the thing about
them though they were interesting
because they were put on display by a
manager as like a lot of you know the
human oddities were back then but after
that you know they they did that for
like three years and then they started
thinking well their manager was like
[ __ ] them over like cheating them
still like we're going out on our own
and we're doing this like on our own
[ __ ] terms and that's what they did
and they actually ended up becoming like
[ __ ] world famous you know for being
then that was kind of like their own
thing doing it was weird is that they
got married they did and they were
actually had kids they were very
financially successful they had 21 kids
between them what they did they married
two women that were sisters the funny
thing about it was that their wives did
not get along so what they did was they
had I guess they had like two houses
that were like next to each other and
then like they would stay in like one
house for three days and then this house
in three days in this house three days
they would like go back and forth you
know what I mean years which i think is
like can you imagine the way that they
were connected they had to be having sex
with the people in the same room with
what obviously had to be like seeing
what the [ __ ] was going on is some weird
[ __ ] we well yeah because he couldn't
leave generally he was just right there
yeah he was just like next to you some
kinky [ __ ] man
there's nothing I could do and I think
the kink was part of what [ __ ] was going
on with these Siamese twins anyway the
attraction
that might have been why people were
into they were so interested in what the
[ __ ] was going on that's a night thing
it is kind of interesting cuz they were
like big celebrities in the media and
that might have been what like part of
the even though people might not have
wanted to admit it they'd probably be
more willing to admit it nowadays you
have zero because I will admit yeah that
it's like having children yeah and it's
like you know there are still like you
know conjoined twins being born nowadays
obviously because I've seen some of them
like on reality shows and [ __ ] like that
but it's like it's yeah and it's like
you all of the [ __ ] that you do in your
life like private kind of stuff you have
to think that every single thing that
you do is shared with another person who
was like right they're always like you
can't get away from them yeah and it's
like what I mean I know they're used to
it because they don't know any different
but it's like what would that be like
yeah the outsiders are were thinking
about that I think that's why that's
what I mean I think that because it's a
fascinating thing to think about
probably for them it's not a big deal
because like I said they they were born
like that they don't know any different
but it's like for other people thinking
oh my god like what would it be like to
just have summit like your sibling like
just right there like all the time like
you can't get away from here screwing
some chick and [ __ ] knocking her up
and your brothers with you well yeah
because he would have to yeah yeah and
and and people in the media are going
like man it's going on yeah it's like
get some hardcore [ __ ] and I think
that's why they were as famous as they
were I think yeah I think that was
probably because people were thinking
about that they were yeah they weren't
they were sexual walking about it but
they were thinking about oh yeah I'm
sure today we're reading between the
lines and I think that's why the
newspaper for following these stories so
closely and why they had fans yeah cuz
people were thinking about that yeah
they're like that's um that's a very
natural thing for people you think about
I mean I think about that sense to me
yeah now the thing about it is that like
I said they ended up making a [ __ ] ton
of money they bought like a big
plantation dance slaves and everything
they like had a big plantation in North
Carolina and like I said they had the
two houses like with the two wives it
didn't get along in there like next-door
and stuff
the shitty thing about this is like and
this always kind of bums me out but it's
like one of one of the twins died like
the one twin like wakes up and the other
one's dead and it's like they call a
doctor to like do an emergency like
separation and stuff but that he didn't
get there in time so the other twin died
like three hours later yeah and I heard
I don't know if this is true or not but
I heard that when the one twin died like
the other twin was kind of like
accepting of it it's like okay we'll
just like put his body like closer to me
and I'm just gonna lay here and he cuz
he knew he was gonna die because it was
like they didn't share a lot of organs
the two of them because like I said they
just had arteries to death
I think their livers were connected but
I think that was the only thing they
they it wasn't like us because some
conjoined twins like share some organs
like in common I think they were pretty
much almost two separate people I think
their livers were connected but that
might have been yeah and you would think
that in an emergency you could have just
[ __ ] sliced him yeah right down the
middle and well they didn't I'm a doc
but by the time the doctor got there I'm
like to the other yeah it was our it was
too late and the other guy was already
done so it's like I that was like creepy
so it must be creepy knowing that like
once that sibling dies it's like you're
gonna die too and it's like you just
have to wait dead body that's what I
mean it's like you can't there's nothing
you do about there was something they
were trading between the two blood yeah
like I said I think their livers were
connected I think they both had a liver
like on their own but I think they were
allayed you've gone in there [ __ ] an
hour or so afterwards they just chopped
it to a part you probably would have had
a much better chance of survival then
they'll just let him sit there like that
waiting for a doctor I'll just grab him
and give me a damn give me a damn
kitchen knife yeah her cleavers yeah and
[ __ ] the hot iron I'm gonna cut him
like that and cauterize it
yeah cuz I imagine he bleed like that
yeah well then I always kind of freaked
me out and like I said I saw him like um
this was several years ago but I saw
like a show on like [ __ ] TLC or
whatever where they they had a pair of
conjoined twins who one of the girls was
like you know a normal like well-formed
person and then she had a sister that
was kind of like I guess she wasn't they
were at
did the head but she had like her own
brain and she has a but she was like she
couldn't like reach the floor so she
always had to have like a wheelchair
like this she took around like with her
and like I said she didn't know any
different because she'd been born like
that so it wasn't really that big a deal
but it's like I always kind of thought
to myself it's like what happens if like
one of them
I remember those girls there yeah
there's constantly kind of banter back
and forth kind of mindless [ __ ] they're
not that intelligent
well they yeah well they're always kind
of like talking to each other but they
showed them like Oh back in a wallet so
yeah they actually kind of if you take
all of them wheelchairs away they kind
of look like a spider yeah when you
talking about
um dolled your arms and legs maybe well
no I said she looks like a no she looks
like a regular girl she's one of them
looks like almost a person but the other
the sister like they're attached at the
head yeah yeah and she's kind of like a
little person I'm thinking I'm thinking
of the two guys that are going out
together and they're kind of like a damn
spider well yeah the four arms of four
legs and they can move it's weird
it's weird that last time I saw them
those back in the [ __ ] very early 90s
yeah I don't know if they're still alive
or not yeah I don't think they weren't
totally mentally with it from what our
you know based on what I remember yeah
we'll see but yeah so yeah that was some
wheat that was some weird conjoined
twins yeah it was like one body with a
bunch of arms and legs coming out of it
yeah that's like a different thing I
feel like you know Chang and Eng were
essentially two separate people that
were just like connected they didn't
share a lot of I mean like I said their
livers were fused yeah but that was it
it was just like their abdomen they
didn't have like it wasn't kind of a
thing where you know sometimes you see
conjoined twins that are just like you
know one person is just like half of a
person and like they share the legs and
the pelvis and everything like that it
wasn't like that they were both like
completely they could walk on their own
and [ __ ] like that but they were just
like attached in the middle you know now
some other ones that were kind of famous
and we'll kind of get into PT Barnum
here too because the
- were kind of like you know associated
with PT barn - this was Maximo and Bart
Ola now these were I believe they're
from El Salvador now this was a brother
and sister and they both had but they
were both microcephalic and had you know
developmental disabilities now in the
19th century these two were exhibited in
what they used to call human zoos which
is what you're thinking it is that's
it's pretty much exactly what you're
thinking of so um the this was a case
where these two were born and I guess
their mother didn't know what to do with
them so the mother actually sold them to
a merchant and the merchant said hey
I'll take them too you know I'll take
them to a city and like exhibit them and
Stefon like make money off them and
stuff so the mother said okay and she
took money and everything like that so
they ended up for whatever reason they
ended up being billed as the Aztec
children and there was like this whole
it wasn't true but there was like this
whole elaborate backstory like concocted
about them it's like they were found in
in a temple and like this lost
Mesoamerican temple or something like
that that that's where they had been
discovered so they ended up actually
kind of touring Europe and touring the
United States and you know various like
kings and you know other people saw them
and stuff
PT Barnum actually ended up putting them
in his museum in 1860 now the weird
thing about this was that in 1867 they
married them to each other even though
they were brother and sister they were
like I think what um like I said there
were microcephalic like I said back in
the old days they would call that a
pinhead and they also have like really
really big
ephram's yeah so I guess this made them
look there's a lot of like promotional
photos of them I think I have some that
I'll put in the in the video in the
video but it's like they I don't know
why they call them the Aztec children
that was usually what they were billed
as but the two of them were like they
have these big
this big huge hair and they have like
the little bitty the little bitty heads
and stuff like that and then they
married them to each other even though
they're brother and sister it's like
other it was like well they weren't
having sex is all this all promotional
that's what I mean and I do feel like
and cuz like I show like I mentioned
earlier it was very common you know in
sideshow culture the most common thing
was to have dear fat lady marry your
human skeleton yeah
like sometimes they were really in love
and they married like legit and
everything but it's like a lot of times
they would just do that it's like a
publicity stunt because then they could
go on the road is like the world's
weirdest married couple that's like it's
a big [ __ ] thing you know they do like
a Jack Sprat could eat no fat his wife
could eat no lean kind of thing
so they would do that kind of [ __ ] where
it's like look at this big huge fat
woman and surely married those two
together and they told the public they
weren't related they just happen to be
you know they just look yeah yeah yeah I
think that's exactly what they were
doing so it's kind of like you know it's
kind of shitty so let's talk a little
bit about PT Barnum because I feel like
PT Barnum was the guy even though there
had been quote-unquote freak shows going
back to probably the 16th century if not
earlier he was the guy that kind of at
least in the United States like kind of
he codified it and you made it like a
thing he industrialized all that he did
yeah it really did seem like his kind of
marketing savvy and you know his whole
thing about it was I mean his American
Museum in New York
that was kind of like the catalyst for
you know when he opened in the 1840s
this is my era this is an era where
what's the beginning of what you would
call today the media yeah so now that
you have a media you can operate within
it and mass-market [ __ ] and then you
know I mean and this is the beginning of
the modern media that you know today
which is now kind of dying because of
the internet but yeah PT Barnum yeah and
like I said I eating us really what do
you think about genius II was actually I
feel like he gets I mean he gets [ __ ] on
a lot for various things which some of
which is deserved but I do feel like a
lot of the stuff he said like I said you
know there's a sucker born every minute
there's no proof that he said that one
of the quotes
that I wrote down that he'd actually
probably did say was I don't believe in
duping the public but I believe in first
attracting and then pleasing them he was
just trying to make something that
people would enjoy and that they would
pay to see if you had to kind of
[ __ ] to get them to come in there
and it just then so be it
he wasn't above that well that was part
of the game exactly it was wise enough
usually to understand when they were
when they were being stood that way
hey nuke and I I feel like part of his
genius too was that and one of his very
earliest things this is may be quite
famous but one of the first things he he
did that was a hoax was very kind of
early on in his career he found this
woman whose name was Joice Heth and she
was a blind woman she was a former slave
he at least her for $1000 from whoever
now he kind of put her on the road as a
woman that was a hundred and sixty years
old and had been a nanny to George
Washington that's a good angle so yeah
so he kind of like took her on the road
and this earned like a lot of money at
the time because she would come up and
she was she was blind and stuff but she
was like she implied she liked tell
stories better with you George
Washington and like how awesome it was a
kid [ __ ] like that so this was like one
of his earliest things now after the
woman died poor woman after she died
like doctors terms she's probably only
been in her 80s or something like that
she wasn't a hundred and 60 obviously
but it's like I
I don't think PT Barnum I don't think he
actually cared so much about the truth
as like what he could kind of get away
of course this is show business that's
what I mean it's all very showbiz and I
feel like as long as you're not being
yeah he's being deceptive but in a way I
kind of feel like this is sort of like
the equivalent nowadays of like you
remember that discovery show documentary
about the mermaids
exactly I you know I was baked yeah
you mean even you what you wanted that
you knew that was fake but it was I
think everybody watched it my dad didn't
know it was fake my dad oh yeah he did
think it was real and I'm sure a few
people - head is straighten that out
with it like that what's clearly not but
you know once people get to a certain
age they just see most people knew that
it was nothing oh they'll get lost and
don't get lost in fantasy but you know
it's uh people PT Barnum gave people
what they wanted to see yeah okay that
that was this show that they wanted and
he was kind of like one of these I mean
he was like almost solely responsible
for the sideshow attraction becoming
like so popular because when he opened
his American Museum which it was a
museum that he purchased from someone
else and he like reopened in 1841 I have
like you know wax figures it had like
all kinds sort of museum exhibits but
also this kind of like he added like all
these human oddities and stuff this was
like I saw him this documentary that
they're saying this at the time this was
more people came to this museum in a
year then went to like Disneyland like
nowadays you know what I mean so it's it
was a huge [ __ ] deal and the fact
that it was so popular caused many other
ones to open they said like even just in
New York City alone there were like
hundreds of what they called dime
museums which were kind of like you know
a museum that had that sort of stuff and
it like pickled punks and human oddities
and that kind of stuff and it like
sideshow type of stuff as opposed to
like art museum with like you know fine
art and stuff in it so he was kind of
responsible for I guess mainstreaming
the sideshow type show in the United
States and making it a thing where and
it was even him that even though he had
like his American Museum which actually
burned down a couple of times but um he
had like all his you know human oddities
he had all his displays and stuff and
actually a lot of the quote-unquote
freaks like lived on the premises
because it's a big huge building so they
actually like had rooms like upstairs
and stuff so the fact that he had that
and then he
had the idea of taking it on the road as
you know like on trains and stuff so
that kind of like popular right I'm not
saying he invented it cuz he didn't but
I do think that he popularized it to an
extent that it became like an American
cultural phenomenon so I think he was
responsible for that you know what I
mean yeah well I was like TV before it's
time yeah yeah and he goes like all
around the [ __ ] country like you know
what I mean the [ __ ] was like jumbo the
elephant and all that kind of stuff and
yeah and he was probably sending out a
bunch of leaflets before the and he had
guys he'd have guys hyping it he like he
was not dumb he like knew a lot of
marketing [ __ ] that people do now like
he knew that back then like in the mid
19th century he was like before like
when he started touring around with the
show and he would like you know partner
with other circuses and stuff like that
and buy other circuses you know at some
point too
this is a time when America had mega
cities yeah
and mega cities that are now gone you
know like Gary and [ __ ] places like
Detroit yeah gone now you know I mean so
you would sit there and [ __ ] send
dudes out ahead of you as they tell the
shows coming and there's all yeah and
that's what they did he had dudes that
went out into the town ahead and that
was like their whole job was they were
supposed to go to the town that they
were going to next and he'd they were
supposed to like hype the show up yeah
and get it all [ __ ] so you could do a
big circuit around the United States if
I can hit all the major cities and make
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of money and he did
yeah I mean he went bankrupt a couple
times and like I said his museum burned
down a couple of times which is kind of
sad because like he lost not only a lot
of displace but he lost like a lot of
animals um you know very famously like
jumbo the very famous elephant was
killed in a train wreck a very bad train
wreck um but the thing about PT Barnum
is like that happened like jumbo was one
of his biggest drawers because it was
like internationally famous that
gigantic elephant and after jumbo died
in the train wreck
the first thing he thought of is like
well now we have to like take the
skeleton and make it into like a display
and take the skin and make that into a
display also so it's like he was always
thinking of an angle like to make money
which sounds I mean to us it sounds like
kind of tacky and stuff but it's like he
was just trying to like toss a coin man
it's like you just had to like scramble
for every dollar and that's what he was
doing and he was like actually very
successful at doing that so you know
like I said it's questionable as some of
his methods were it's like you do kind
of have to admire his illusion huh was a
man of his time yeah everything was
questionable back in those days in a way
of looting was in a way he was a lot
better than a lot of people you know he
was an early advocate of like you know
slaver like abolition of slavery he was
very vocal and like combating that so
it's like he wasn't a terrible guy he
was actually kind of a nice guy even
well he treated his people well he paid
them very well like some like I said
some of them died millionaires so you
have to look at it in the context of the
time right you know I mean so in that
sense like I said you know I mentioned
in show business May he was a show biz
man look I mean I mention free Hollywood
yeah so you know yeah this is like I
said this is mid to late yeah you know
1800s yeah um we talked earlier about
General Tom Thumb who was actually I
guess he was a distant relative of PT
Barnum um you know like a second cousin
or something like that so he heard about
this kid being born because apparently
General Tom Thumb who was actually born
Charles Stratton as I said he was born
in 1838 now his he was born normal
he was nine pounds you know eight ounces
when he was born and for the first six
months of his life he developed like a
normal baby but then all of a sudden he
stopped growing so after a little while
like PT Barnum heard about this and was
very interested in finding out about
what was going on with that so when he
was four or five years
old PT Barnum like went there and was
like okay well can I take this kid
because I'm gonna like do some [ __ ] with
him so even though like all like all of
Charles Stratton's siblings and
everything like that his parents were
all normal signs but for whatever reason
he just he grew normally till he was six
months old and he stopped growing and
then I feel like he didn't grow and then
like he grew a little bit later on I
think he ended up being a little over
three feet tall like you know at the end
but he um I'm not entirely sure like
what the what the disability was but he
just didn't grip but the thing about him
was that he was not it's it's not like
the kind of dwarfism where they're like
quote unquote
out of proportion he was just very he he
was in proportion he was just very very
very very small that's the kind of
kidney problem or something maybe I'm
not sure because like I said he was like
he was [ __ ] born normal
but so PT Barnum like I said he saw
potential in the kid and like I said the
kid was only four or five years old and
he pretty much took him like for the
parents and he trained the kid to be a
performer like he taught him how to sing
here at I'm gonna dance
he saw that but how to do like
impressions of like famous people of the
time or [ __ ] like that so you saw that
potential yeah and it's like he's gonna
seed it he's gonna say yeah yeah he like
raised a kid yeah which like I said it
sounds [ __ ] up because the kid knows
that on the day that's exactly what you
want but it ended up okay because I mean
and like I said it don't do that today
yeah they did this new world at least in
turn our day in the 70s and the ends
they groomed child stars yeah to be
famous
yeah chickens you know there's a lot of
them that are now [ __ ] growing man
Tom Cruise was almost kind of groomed
from his late teens yeah to be a star I
think Johnny Depp was too did you
yeah I mean when you look at like look
at the way there something like you know
child actors or maybe like you know
beauty queen kind of culture or
something like that and a date went even
further back like Shirley Temple yeah
you know and you know she was groomed
from an early age to be a star yeah when
she got older though she was no longer a
star she was only a child star I think
that happens with a lot of shows yes
well because I think that the thing that
attracts a lot of people do particular
child stars then yes that their children
they're like cute and like they do stuff
but then when they get older it was like
they're not they're not cute anymore so
it's like you're just like everybody
else right every charm is gone
it does seem it's very very even
nowadays it's very unusual for someone
that the child start to go on and you
know yeah I can't even think of that
many more mommy Jodie Foster yeah a more
modern version would have been you know
the [ __ ] brat pack yeah you know and
that's [ __ ] Tom Cruise and all those
people from the [ __ ] 80s that grew up
and they made boobies all throughout the
90s and stuff yeah you know I mean that
would be like the modern version of that
but back in the eighteen hundreds
they've groomed him [ __ ] them from an
early age yeah a lot of money in a
[ __ ] and entertaining kids and yeah
and little child would make a lot of
money and honestly um you can take it
back to the [ __ ] Wolfgang Mozart
Amadeus well his dad like toured
Amalapuram he was it because he was a
chance a little child problem in his
sister was it Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart
yeah yeah and his sister let's not
forget yeah because she was just as
talented as him it's just they're
they're just [ __ ] play piano yeah
[ __ ] how old were they [ __ ] five
six seven if I could tearing it out yeah
their dad what was their dad's name
Leopold I think and he took them like he
toured them like all the way it's not a
new phenomenon yeah I mean if you had a
kid that was that talented then that's
not I mean yeah it seems creepy nowadays
but it's been going on a long time
people didn't live that long anyway stop
they were doing well and like I said I
feel like in the case of General Tom
Thumb or Charles Stratton if you want to
use his real name I mean yes you can
argue that like he was only four
five years old when he was taken in by
PT Barnum and essentially groomed to be
a famous person one his parents were on
board with it they were kind of like
yeah okay do what you want um and you
can argue that his his life turned out
pretty okay I mean he died pretty young
he was only 46 when he died but that
might have been due to his condition and
in that time like I said he met Abraham
Lincoln for chrissake he performed for
Queen Victoria he was internationally
famous he was a millionaire uh else
would you have done that's what I you
know what would the average mother I
didn't feel like at you know as
questionable as how it happened might
have been like he didn't have a lot of
choice in the matter but it did actually
turn out oh yeah that was a blessing
because yeah the average person at that
time never would have lived a life like
that and he actually did seem to I mean
he actually became like PT Barnum's kind
of business partner later on and he and
PT Barnum were actually very very close
friends and like I said he ended up
marrying later it's very funny though
because a very famous photo that shows
that shows General Tom Thumb and mrs.
Tom Tom whose name is Lavinia Warren it
shows them and like a baby
and it's implying that that's their baby
and like look they had a normal-size
avian it's not the biggest it's not
their baby
that's PT Barnum did that a lot he's
like and he's like if I had like human
oddities that it's like and I wanted the
public to think they had had a baby then
it was just the same size them it's like
so he was just borrow somebody a lot
baby the baby and like put the baby in
her [ __ ] picture so the very famous
picture of them with the baby that is
not their baby that's just some like
random baby that's Solaris I know it is
like that's very insane [ __ ] that's
might be it it's like yes [ __ ] 18
hours traveling shoulders [ __ ] out yes
essentially what it is but yeah and like
I said before there was like that whole
[ __ ] rivalry with that other a little
person comment or not and stuff like
that
Commodore net now the the shitty thing
too is just Commodore nut up in all
those [ __ ] well outfits like he was
[ __ ] a [ __ ] a
general well no that's what they did
come it's like he made him a hole yeah I
mean he he said that he was English even
though he wasn't he was a second
but it's like he made him like little
uniforms he made him like a little like
[ __ ] like a little coach the horses
and stuff like that was like made to his
size and stuff and that was like one of
his big things like he would say oh he's
like he made up this whole backstory
about this kid and it's not if it was
true but it's like that's it slowly go
it did and that's kind of like what made
the kids fame and it does really seem
like I mean at the time what plays into
people's [ __ ] imaginations
yeah a little guy who looks just like a
normal guy he's a little general and
he's got a little [ __ ] coach of a
little bitty horses mm-hmm right like he
comes from little people land here yeah
but this bunch of them somewhere you
know somebody is that one of the million
one of the most famous are one of the
best attended kind of sideshow
attractions and I believe it was also in
Coney Island back in the day was called
lilliputian and it was like a little
village that had like 300 little people
in it and everything was like little
size or everything and people like ate
that [ __ ] up I mean so ate that [ __ ] up
listen to a parallel universe where
everybody's a little you sure yeah huge
like a giant yeah so I you know I can
see how people would be into that cuz I
said yeah when I was telling a story
when I was a little kid in the [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] the ship comes down
remember that night yeah it's like hot
cherry filling yeah yeah the regular
listeners know exactly what we're
talking about new people like what the
[ __ ] is Tom talking about dream I had I
was out I used to dig in my backyard a
lot when I was a little kid if I can put
the garden hose and make rivers and
[ __ ] mountains and [ __ ] well I had a
dream I was out there doing that and I
made a little River and all of a sudden
a [ __ ] Spanish galleon come sailing
down those it does and it's like [ __ ]
four feet long big old [ __ ] Spanish
Galion and I'm looking at it amazed and
you assembly Sam about what six six inch
tall you seventy Sam shooting at me with
his pistols like grab him bite the top
of his head and he was filled with
cherry filling burn my mouth like a
pop-tart it's [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] ever
man kids dream about felt like I love
that you still remember it I felt like I
was the size of Godzilla
yeah I've often had fans along those
lines yes as of Godzilla's sometimes
yeah okay let's finish this story but
we're ganna get drunk [ __ ] I'm getting
drunk [ __ ] talking about me being
bigger than Godzilla and fighting yours
Amity Sam and [ __ ] well okay so since we
were talking about little people let's
talk about a little bit about the most
one of the most famous human skeletons
okay and that was Isaac W sprog okay now
this guy he was born in 1841 in
Massachusetts now he was normal for most
of his childhood however when he turned
12
he inexplicably started losing weight
okay like he was going swimming and he
started feeling kind of sick and then
all of a sudden like I'll just wait
started falling off him yeah um and
apparently like he ate Nate Nate but it
didn't really make any difference like
he just kept losing weight um so
nowadays I don't think they knew what it
was at the time nowadays they would have
call it like progressive muscular
atrophy okay um but because of his
condition he had a hard time like
keeping a job because his if you saw him
later on his life like in some of the
photos of him he when he was an adult he
only waited 46 pounds like his head was
normal size but his art he had like no
it was just like bone with skin over it
46 pounds yes [ __ ]
yeah yeah there's nothing yeah so the
problem was like he couldn't really hold
it like his dad was a cobbler so he did
that for a little while but like I said
he couldn't really do it because he
didn't have any like all his muscle was
like gone so after his parents died he
didn't
have any other way to support himself so
he got offered a job at a circus
sideshow in 1865 and he took it billing
himself as the living skeleton and in
1866 PT Barnum saw him in another circus
and actually hired him to work at his
American Museum which had reopened
subsequent because it had burned down
and he had rebuilt it instead of like
that
um spraga actually got $80 a week at the
time which got a money back yeah yeah it
was quite a lot of money back then like
I said he was Barnum was actually quite
well known for paying his entertainers
quite well so it's kind of it's creepy
because you you see pictures of him like
I said you know that he has a condition
but it's just like well they couldn't
fix it back then no back then like I
said I did they didn't know what it was
and he couldn't like have a regular job
and like I said this was like 1860s now
so make some money they didn't have like
disability payments but we're like you
know you couldn't work you would get
money and you could like feed yourself
at least yeah they didn't have that you
really yeah it's like what else could
you do right so he actually did end up
having a fairly normal life like he did
get married he actually ended up having
three sons all of whom were normal which
is very weird apparently though he also
had a bit of a gambling problem which
kind of you know Brenda problems so yeah
he was when he was 44 years old he was
five foot six inches tall and weighed 43
pounds
and he they said that he was apparently
like he could his body wouldn't like
retain nutrients I guess so it's like he
had to like be constantly eating and
they said that he the story was that he
used to have a flask around his neck
that had milk in it because he like
constantly had a drink in like because
trying to stay alive he was just like
trying to stay alive because otherwise
he would kind of like go unconscious and
stuff he actually ended up dying quite
early in 1887 there was
ever figured out what it was not really
nowadays they would call it like
progressive muscular atrophy they know
what it is now but at the time they
didn't and he was actually quite poor
when he died he died of asphyxia in 1887
now he was kind of like the original
living skeleton so he was kind of like
the first one to do that so in
successive freak shows
they were also like ever like skinny
dudes would come and be like living
skeletons and they would be like that
and like I said it was very common for
them to marry like the circus family
yeah the funny thing about it though is
that if you look at pictures of you know
the fat ladies from back in the day it's
like you can see fatter people than that
nowadays it like Walmart and stuff so
it's like I feel like people aren't
gonna pay to see that nowadays because
it's not that fat people will rare back
then that's what I mean it's like it
seemed like somebody that was like six
or seven hundred pounds that was like
people would pay to see that cuz they're
like wow that's some freaky [ __ ] but
it's like nowadays it's still kind of
freaky but not to the extent that you'd
pay to see it because like I said you
can go to Walmart and see that for free
yeah what's on the on the cart yeah and
like I said they even have like the show
my sixth Center pound life where you can
see like eight nine hundred pound people
I'm just wondering what they ate back
then because the food [ __ ] sucked back
in there that's right how could you eat
enough food of that [ __ ] Victorian to
be seven hundred pounds
Victorian food I kind of have to admire
that because like I said the food back
then was so shitty sucked yeah it's like
what were they eating
it was [ __ ] [ __ ] most of it and
it wasn't like oh now I'm curious yeah
unsafe [ __ ] this is why I kind of
feel like some people know spice food
yeah because I do feel like I I mean I
know that I've I've read interviews with
other carnies and they're saying that
like you know the the Fat Lady's of the
fat men from the old time carnivals it's
like I've never met one that had like a
quote-unquote glandular condition that
made them fat it was always like they
got fat because they ate a lot but I
feel like maybe yeah maybe nowadays
but I feel like back in the day it was
probably more likely to be a glandular
condition because you could choke down
enough for that food to like way that
much yeah [ __ ] I feel like it has
some like genetic predisposition aged
pheasant and [ __ ] is what they ain't
back that you have hamburger that's
right nowadays a lot of nowadays it
would be very easy to be in that person
oh yeah in a carnival I could do that
very easily yeah it probably only take
me a month or two yeah
and I would enjoy the process but you
don't have it so I'm just I'm just gonna
I'm gonna eat all the donuts I'm just
gonna listen I'm just gonna go in two
years
take a couple but you know what I mean
it's I feel like back then it was
probably harder because the food was so
much shitty and nasty they were just
like oh I'm just so hungry now
PT Barnum also had a British equivalent
this guy's name was Tom Norman now he
was a guy that in the Victorian era was
also kind of like had a traveling
carnival he also had a woman that was
called the skeleton woman very skinny
woman named Eliza Jenkins he had
something called a balloon headed baby
imagination he also had kind of a geek
exhibit like a woman that bit the heads
off live rats jeez yes what a flea
circus he had some fat ladies get a
giant some dwarves and this is my
favorite he also had a bunch of white
dudes I guess they had been sailors he
painted the black and they and gave them
like a made-up language to speak and
called them the savage Zulus apparently
he also had when he called a family of
midgets which was actually just two guys
and some baby that he'd borrowed from
someone he didn't know so he was like
traveling around London was apparently
very successful now Tom Norman became
famous because of his association with
the even more famous Elephant Man yeah
guys haven't seen their he haven't seen
the movie that deliverance maybe you
haven't seen a David Lynch movie called
alpha man guy it's like it's bad enough
he had this [ __ ] happen to him but it's
like he have like the worst
in life effort it was a you know I mean
it's almost kind of like Marik damn
Joseph Mary Joseph that's actually a
common mistake it's because that there
was a play made about his life where
they mistakenly called him John that was
not the same his name was actually
Joseph if you haven't seen that movie
the Elephant Man you got its you got to
see it I feel like the movie is like
even less of a bummer than the dude's
actual life yeah you know I mean we grew
up what you saying something we grew up
watching that [ __ ] on [ __ ] on HBO yeah
and that movie there man if I can tear
your heart out it really it doesn't
sound so bad for that dude yeah can you
imagine it's like and that like I said
it was a real person yeah so yeah Joseph
Merrick like met Tom Norman in 1884 now
Joseph Merrick um he was actually from a
Leicester in England now he was a normal
up until he was five years old but for
whatever reason once it once he turned
five he started like developing these
weird like shapes on his head well yeah
well like he started getting these weird
like lumps on his skin and like they
didn't really know what it was his bones
were just growing out of control just
yeah well I at the time they always have
like this weird like sympathetic magic
kind of approach to like medicine so
it's kind of like at first they thought
well maybe it was because when you were
in the womb like your mom was scared by
an elephant and now it's like coming
back to haunt you or something like that
yes so that's kind of like how they
thought of they thought he looked like
an elephant cuz he had a big-ass
forehead yeah and but he didn't look
like an elephant to me just look like
damn mutant head was just blowing up
yeah it was like three feet around yeah
and it was just like all kinds of you
see the movie the Elephant Man if you
think your life is bad watch that
[ __ ] movie yeah you will feel a lot
better about because [ __ ] put the
poor [ __ ] guy it's like there's
nothing he could do about it and there's
like it's an excellent movie it is
really well it's black and white
no sound though black and white and
black and white movie at a time when
movies were color yeah but it's a black
and
movie and it's got old what's-his-name
that played in the damn [ __ ]
what's-his-name the guy who guy who
played [ __ ] Silence of the Lambs
Anthony Anthony Hopkins he plays a good
guy and John Hurt and it's just like
damn because like I said it's like this
kind of thing like I said the kid was 5
years old he was normal and then all of
a sudden he starts developing these
deformities and when he gets a little
bit older I mean his mom died when he
was 11 like his mom died of pneumonia
and by that point he wasn't like
completely deformed but he was starting
to go that way he did finish school like
you know what I mean because he still
looked normal enough and he was able to
like have a job in his teenage years he
actually first had a job like rolling
cigars I believe but as time went on his
deformities became so severe that he
could no like his hand and everything
like that like he couldn't work anymore
and there are photographs of this dude
just do yeah I have some he really did
look that way and then make matters
worse Michael Jackson bought a skeleton
eventually I think that's an urban
legend I think I think Michael Jackson
did have his skeletal yeah yeah but yeah
the the shitty thing too is that his
deformities eventually became so severe
that he couldn't really like he couldn't
really talk in a way that other people
can understand him you know what I mean
he was a perfectly like intelligent
human being but like his speech was
slurred like because his head was so
deformed so he ended up having to go to
like a workhouse which he hated as you
would back in the [ __ ] Victorian era
and his dad would also like beat him
because he wasn't making any money which
that's nice
but you know so after like you know he
had gone to this workhouse he's about 17
years old at this point and he's like
you know I hate this so I'm gonna try
and like put myself like kind of on
display you know to try to have a better
life so he actually did kind of put
himself on displays like half man half
Elif
when he went out in public he tried to
like put like a bag over his head or
like a big cape or a hat and stuff like
that some people can see it but I mean
at some point like the deformities were
so bad that it couldn't really be all
that hidden anymore he did also get a
lot of like visits from doctors and
stuff like that at the time I don't
think they really knew what it was um
even nowadays that is a very very
unusual condition some kind of bone some
kind of mutation yeah it's just like
some kind of like out-of-control growth
bone growth yeah bone and you know and
tumors and things like that because he
just had this [ __ ] thing now he did
eventually end up befriending a surgeon
named Frederick Treves who like you said
was played by Anthony Hopkins in the
movie and so those two developed a
friendship and they kind of became
friends but he did kind of go around
like displaying himself and stuff like
that and he became very famous but the
problem like he died it's sad because he
died so young it's like he died at 27
now it may have been Seuss they're not
yet they're not sure if it was suicide
because he look his head was so big that
he had to sleep sitting up with his head
like resting on his knees like that
because he couldn't put his head back
it's suffocating yeah and what he ended
up doing one day when he was 27 was it
looked as though he had tried to sleep
quote-unquote like a normal person and
it had broken his neck and he had like
asphyxiated because hit like I said his
head was so heavy that he couldn't lay
down he would die so I feel like he
probably did that on purpose
you don't think Michael Jackson had his
skeleton oh I don't know I just thought
it was I thought that was an urban
legend I'd always heard that Michael
Jackson [ __ ] loved that movie and had
a lot of compassion for that character
and that he had bought his may be
amongst a bunch of other weird [ __ ] that
he owned yeah he might've had it I'm not
really sure about I think I
that's how I remembered how they but he
had spayed several he'd be over
$1,000,000 I just always I've always
felt so bad for that guy because it
everyone that knew him um you know said
that he was just like the nicest dude
and it's just like for that to happen to
him like there's nothing can you do
about it it's like nothing that he did
that caused it it just happened and it's
like a curse yeah and it was and that's
like the shitty thing I think like
hearing about that when I was a kid was
one of the things that kind of convinced
was like well the universe doesn't give
a [ __ ] about any of us if you haven't
seen that movie you better go see that
movie no crime no cry oh man I did that
[ __ ] I was a little kid that [ __ ] sir
didn't traumatize you just it's awful it
just opens your eyes to what the
possibilities are the yeah very [ __ ]
lucky yeah and that poor guy and like I
said he died movie was 27 and like I
said if I kind of feel like he probably
just got sick of it and was just like
come here and I said I'm just gonna like
lay down I think in person I I think you
did too and and honestly I can't blame
him
because even though he was trapped in a
[ __ ] weird-ass [ __ ] body and just
and there was nothing he could do about
it was getting worse he was still boys
yeah and even nowadays that is a very
very very rare condition yeah but you
know especially back then like what
could you have done and it's like the
thing is it's that even after he went
like on display and stuff it's like
people were still throwing rocks at him
and like you know when he would appear
in public like he tried to like keep a
burlap sack over his face and everything
like that but even then like people were
still very hostile toward him yeah
because of some weird-ass genetic
condition yeah it's like he couldn't
help it it's just time didn't when it
was a kid and it's just like this is
it's very very sad so um so like I said
I I feel like after a certain time
period especially after medical science
started to like kind of catch up with
figuring out what was causing these
particular types of disabilities I feel
like the public you know particularly in
the very late 19th century early 20th
century work
kind of getting to a point where it's
like they started feeling kind of bad or
kind of guilty about leering at these
people like in freak shows and stuff
even though the freaks themselves
quote-unquote might have been okay with
it
I do feel like the public was kind of
losing its taste for that type of stuff
and I think after the advent of
television and like other things where
you could see that stuff like you know
routinely so it seems like the the age
of the sideshow was kind of complication
right it's in heavy exotics ISM that it
used to have because they weren't like
you Ernest understood what it was like I
said you could see photographs of it and
everything like that and also they were
kind of a lot of kind of laws started
coming into effect where it's like you
were not allowed to display like
deformed for money you couldn't show
like human fetuses for money like that
and in the United States late
18-hundreds very early nineteen hundred
socially around the 20s eugenics
movements started to come in you know
they were trying to people worried about
selective breeding and strengthening the
race is what they called it they didn't
want the people like this to be born
yeah anymore you know and I mean so
there was selective breeding and
abortion you know well yeah and I think
that kind of started see like the more
that they started doing you know the
more that the technology started to
progress and where people could see like
you know they'd have amniocentesis and
stuff like that where you could see
these types of deformities like before
the children were born so it happened a
lot less raw like you don't see it as
much anymore because people can catch it
like early on yeah the beginnings of all
that eugenics movements almost was kind
of like the beginning of a damn Syfy
movement there was a lot of science
fiction involved with this too people
don't don't realize that you know
utopian thinking is science fiction
that's where a lot of us started yeah
with you know writers like Jules burned
as he started all that
who is the one that did brave new world
Huk South exactly yeah this guy started
to come in that we could build a perfect
world with perfect people in a perfect
system and utopian thinking ended up by
the time the 1930s rolled around being
very [ __ ] problematic because then you
started getting communism and [ __ ]
German National Socialism which are
different there are a reaction to this
really yeah trying to make a perfect
world when you're trying to make a
perfect world you're you're playing
you're trying to play God and when you
try to become God and godlike then that
means you're selecting who's gonna be
born whose cannot be born yeah and who
has the right to live and who doesn't
and then all of a sudden you start
having guys analyzing [ __ ] race and
culture all that [ __ ] we talked about
earlier all starts to factor in where
you start having people were in our
democracy we can't have these people
over here because they have a genetic
predisposition for voting this and that
and their races against our race so I'm
gonna wipe them out
and you know that's that's what a human
nature it is like a slippery slope
slippery slope how far are you gonna
take this I can see okay like I can see
to an extent you know like I said the
onset of you know amniocentesis better
like prenatal care and stuff like that I
can see how individually a woman that is
pregnant you know if you were given the
choice hey you know the child that you
were bearing has X Y Z like deformity or
whatever do you want to deal with that
or not you know I can see how that is
that individual that is her body that is
her baby so it's like I can see how at
that stage you know yes that can be and
I think anybody who's honest if you know
you're gonna give birth to the damn
Elephant Man it's better that you should
not give birth to the well because you
don't just because of the damn is suffer
yeah I wouldn't want me I if I knew that
I was gonna give birth to Joseph Merrick
and then yeah he was gonna like spend
his entire life miserable like that and
die the way he died not that's not right
it's like so I would not really want you
know I wouldn't want to bring him into
the world to suffer like the way that he
suffered so you know to me that seems
just like you know a human thing to do I
think the problem arises when you're
taking it when you're taking the choice
out of like individual mother's hands
say and like making it's like well we
don't think that you should have this
type of baby or we don't think that
these people should that's like you know
what I mean when when it's not like the
individuals your mother's choice anymore
yeah that's kind of like you start
talking about like the Chinese one-child
policy
who's the Chinese state to say how many
children you can have if you can afford
four or five of them then who says that
you can't have four or five children
yeah that's why I'm kind of like I have
a problem with kind of like I don't know
it's just way too thank you government
starts crawling into your vagina yeah
that's you know what I mean it's like
you can't tell people that they can't
have abortions you can't tell people how
many children they can have you can't
tell it's like just get on the other out
of there and on the other hand you
shouldn't tell them how many children
they should have that's what I mean it's
like just don't one way or the other
seems like it's it's a very fine line
between your kind of like like I said
don't be crawling into my womb man it's
like I don't but then again you know I
mean I'm kind of torn about it I don't
believe you should give birth to
children that are just gonna suffer that
it's not real well now for my own
personal like if I you know and but I
also think you should have born Kent
yeah I think you should avoid killing
the unborn but then you also have to
[ __ ] there's mitigating mitigating
circumstances can the family unit
support the children there's a bunch of
different ways that's what I mean that's
why I don't think you should take that
person's choice away because you don't
know that person's life I think the
mother should decide the mother should
decide because ultimately it is her
that's going to be at the Razr that's
going to have to raise it that's going
to have to deal with it so I feel like
ultimately it should be her decision
there shouldn't be any other kind of
like you know I mean it's like can she
afford it it you know is this child
going to have like certain deformities
it's like issue prepared
with that yeah it's like is she gonna be
forced to raise a child she didn't want
them right it's like so and here's the
deal here's the deal I'm not on the left
I'm actually on the right and I believe
women have the right to choose if
they're gonna be a mother or not yeah I
just don't believe they should be forced
to if I could be a mother that's what I
mean and I'm there I'm very I'm very
much on the Left yes anyone don't know
but it's like you know I'm leery but
should be forced into that role exactly
and that's exactly how I look at it
because that to me it seems like anyone
that's trying to make a laws that are
regulating my uterus right that is very
offensive to me well another thing that
happens is is that you then you end up
having children they're like [ __ ] Ted
Bundy you have these unwanted children
that [ __ ] are born but then some of
them and pee and [ __ ] that's what I mean
and it ages like look at like the bad
side of abortion but it's like the good
side of abortion is that yeah all the
children that are had are wanted right
all of those children are wanted you
know what I mean so if a child is wanted
it's much more likely that it will turn
out okay because you like raised it
there's a bunch because you wanted it
yeah if you were giving birth - yeah
because you had to because you couldn't
get an abortion because you didn't have
any option it's risky yeah it's like you
don't know how that shit's gonna turn
out and you know I just don't think
that's a wise thing to be like forcing
on other people but here in the United
States the whole conversation about this
is very dishonest when you hear the
political conversation of when you hear
how the political conversation of a bore
abortion how it's argued out on YouTube
it's very dishonest to be honest
whenever I hears dudes talking about
abortion I'm just like shut the [ __ ] up
it's the woman that had what the hell
you do you know you don't know anything
you don't get pregnant you don't have to
deal with the consequences you don't
have to deal with any of it so I mean in
my opinion you shouldn't even be talking
about it it's none of your concern
it's the woman that honestly it's none
of your concern if you knock up some
chick you're not married to and then you
don't really have a say that's what I
mean I really don't think you have a say
all right it's only if it's like it's
just married to that well
it's a different man okay that then we
can talk about it but still it's still
her body and it's still her decision
ultimately because she's the one that
has to suffer for it she's the one
that's probably gonna have to raise it
because you know let's be honest about
it you know what I mean so I do feel
like it just kind of like makes me laugh
in a way that it is like you have to
laugh so you don't cry when I hear dudes
talking about like abortion rights and
stuff like I'm just like why are you
even talking this is nothing to do with
you I think a lot of that there's
nothing to do we think a lot of that
element of that argument you're talking
about though I think a lot of that's
gone by now though well hopefully yeah
because that like a lot of old days I
was trying to do that [ __ ] I'm like
please die I guess I think that was the
argument of the 80s because the man
I think that was the argument of the 80s
I don't really hear that being talked
about in social media the way it was
back in the 80s I still kind of hear it
nowadays it's it was my god it was like
our crab it's not as bad as it was dark
red when you sound like the religious
right and all that kind of crap which
the religious and the old-school rule is
just right there their take on it was
I'm like get the [ __ ] now get the [ __ ]
out of here
yeah this is nothing to do with you
nothing but I'd but you're not you're
not acknowledging what I'm saying Jenny
I don't think that's the argument
anymore
because like those people are mostly
gone I don't know about that though I
just don't hear that anymore oh well I
still do Dave but do you hear that from
the left or you hear that from the right
from there right okay oh yeah who when
the right is saying that oh my goodness
really I don't know I didn't know where
you been but okay okay all right so
before we wrap up I seriously I want to
talk about the lobster boy because I
mentioned him earlier and I said we're
gonna talk about him so I said we gonna
talk about the [ __ ] out so as I said
we're talking about the lobster boy
Grady Franklin Stiles jr. now this is a
deformity which I think I pronounced it
wrong earlier but it's called
ectrodactyly so as I said the fingers on
the hands are like fuse together
in his case they were fused together
into two very large so he had what
essentially looked like lobster claws
now his hands and his feet were both
like that that's not very common like a
lot of people with this disability it's
usually just their hands or one hand or
whatever but he had hit both hands and
feet now he um his family actually had a
very long history of this apparently it
had been generations go mess like 1840
like you know particular members of the
family had had this not all of them but
a lot of them so his dad had been a
sideshow performer that had that a
similar kind of thing and [ __ ] like that
now Grady Stiles who was the most famous
lobster boy he displayed himself in a
circus as bobster boy for a very long
time however he was also an alcoholic
and was also very abusive to his family
now he couldn't walk he was in a
wheelchair because like I said he didn't
really have he had only had partial legs
and they were kind of like fused
together so he had um so because of that
he had a lot of like upper body strength
because he couldn't walk so he had to
like develop a lot of upper body
strength to like move around and [ __ ] um
but he was also as I said an alcoholic
and he was also kind of an [ __ ] now
in 1988 on the eve of his daughter's
wedding he shot and killed his
daughter's fiance who she was going to
marry the Navy was dead yeah he's bad so
yes he had anger issues how to shot that
[ __ ] too clearly
yeah so he shoots now he's brought to
trial yeah and he very willingly
apparently was mad at the dude very
willingly like admits yeah yeah I shot
that [ __ ] yeah now he gets
convicted of third-degree murder however
because of his disability um they didn't
want to send him to prison because they
said well the prison doesn't really have
facilities for someone with
his disability so he got probation okay
for shooting and killing a dude yeah
what was the details of the case though
was it more like a self-defense slash
manslaughter not that I've ever seen no
I just think he did not like his
daughter's fiance and decided I'm gonna
shoot that mother
well the prosecution probably said that
well I'm saying everything I've heard
about the case but was there an argument
and then the guy [ __ ] came at him
like he was gonna whip his ass and there
was a fight then the dude shoots the
dude and already on to you that's portly
at story yeah but apparently he was a
big giant douche because what ended up
happening so as I said he was an
alcoholic kind of a violent drunk and
everything like that now he did stop
drinking for a time and during the time
that he had stopped drinking he actually
ended up remarrying cuz he'd been
married several times but he actually
ended up remarrying his first wife whose
name was Teresa but then he started
drinking again and got even worse than
he was before now at this point in the
early 90s I believe was 1992 Teresa
decides I'm gonna kill this [ __ ]
because she couldn't take it anymore so
her and a son from a previous marriage
they hired another like sideshow worker
a 17 year old guy named Chris Wyatt
they gave him $1500 to kill Grady Stiles
that's a boy that's that's a [ __ ]
low-rent hitman right there $1500 well
[ __ ]
that's nothing um dude's a risk in
first-degree murder charges over $1500
it depends on who it was but I might
kill somebody for 50 no that's nothing
so yeah so so they kill the lobster boy
now Chris Wyant was was caught he was a
convicted of second-degree murder he got
27 years in prison Harry Newman who was
the son of you know Teresa he got life
in prison and Teresa was given 43 years
in prison
so yes so there was this whole thing
where and and as I said earlier Grady
Stiles was I believe the fifth or sixth
generation his family that had this
acted actively thing because apparently
that like runs in families and like I
said I read that article early it's on
Fox if you do like a Google search I
think I found it I don't remember what
the Google search was it was kind of
like history of sideshows or something
like that and it was like on the second
page but it's like a Vox article about a
girl that has that just in one hand and
it she was talking about the sideshows
by the seashore
in Coney Island and how she went to the
school there and like learned to fire
heat and stuff like that and it's a
really good article so I would like
recommend it hmm but yeah so this whole
thing about the [ __ ] lobster war
which is like a really famous case and
him getting shot and killed by his wife
and [ __ ] like that but yeah so there's
actually in a bunch of shows like HBO's
carnival and I think in American Horror
Story freaks I think they even like
freakshow
they even had like a character that was
based on Grady Stiles because he was so
famous with his [ __ ] hands and feet
and [ __ ] like that so as I said you know
I feel like the the freakshow like the
the classic ten-in-one freak show even
though there is still a permanent one in
Coney Island that you can still go to
for ten bucks as far as I know that
mostly has working acts fire-eaters and
whatnot I feel like the heyday of that
has gone there's still some modern-day
ones like I said Jim Rose is still
around he started in the 90s that's
mostly working acts as well actually we
do one here and I've actually done
fliers for them
they're called hellzapoppin that do
similar kind of [ __ ] they have like
little people and fire eaters and sword
swallowers and all that kind of stuff
and also like industrial bands and
whatnot so they're still like stuff like
that circulating so I do feel like there
is kind of an effort to you know
maintain that history because I'm
nostalgia stuff yeah it is kind of like
a fringe thing at this point but I can
understand you know the desire to
continue
you like because this is kind of like an
American cultural tradition it's kind of
like trash art in a way and I would be
really sad to see that go because I for
really I've always really liked the
aesthetic I always liked you know the
idea of like the quote unquote carny
lifestyle I was kind of like found
something very like romantic and
appealing about that and I would be like
really sad to see that kind of good by
the wayside even though I can understand
like why that happens because the
culture is so different now in the
economy but I but I am I am glad to see
that some people are still doing that
it's it's kind of like how I was happy
to see that some people are still trying
to do like burlesque shows and like
because that seemed like to have a
little bit of a resurgence like at least
like kind of on the fringe circuit and
stuff like that like people still kind
of do that so I do feel like there's
value in maintaining those kind of
traditions and updating them for a
modern audience it's never gonna be it's
not yeah it's never gonna be mainstream
obviously but I feel like nowadays
that's a good time to do that because
the audience is so you know we have such
kind of niche everything as niches and I
feel like if you can get a big enough
audience that is into that kind of stuff
that will come and see you then you know
this is a good time to do it because you
know does the word mainstream even mean
anything anymore
at this stage yeah like like it used to
it doesn't have the same resonance that
it used to have because everybody's
dream doesn't I mean it's like
everything is so like fragmented which
in a way like people complain about it
but I think it's a good thing because
people are able to like find whatever
they want
I think tailored towards you and it's
yeah how are you subscriptions listen
well yeah and and it's better for the
creators too because you can find it's
like even though you might not like
everybody might know who you are like oh
you're a horror writer you're not gonna
be Stephen King but you can find enough
of an audience within your particular
niche to like make a living and I think
that's a good thing you know what I mean
I think then the era of Stephen King's
are gone right right like I use Chan
I mean you know it's not entirely gone
they're still like you know stuff that
every like cultural [ __ ] that everybody
knows about like you know whether it be
a book or a movie or whatever like
Marvel Universe or Harry Potter or
whatever it is but I do feel like you
know it's better nowadays you can be in
a niche and just appeal to you know what
back then would have been just like an
unserved like minority population but
now there's enough people that will see
your [ __ ] that you can make a living off
that at least if not like be [ __ ] a
millionaire or anything like that
so I feel like the sideshows can maybe
keep going
but appeal to that kind of niche
audience just like I said like a
burlesque show or like anything like
that you're not gonna get millions of
people to go but there's enough people
there's enough interest they're the
people that are into it that would
support you I think so you know what I
mean so I really do hope that that
continues because I love that kind of
[ __ ] you know what I mean
y'alright bum drunk oh my god not wasted
we had to wrap this show up all right
the world is [ __ ] spinning now it all
piled up on me while you were talking I
guess so yeah but probably the same
thing for the audience too that they're
always drinking when we're doing the
show well unless they're driving yes I
hope that's okay
yeah that is yeah she's inside right
yeah yeah that's right she's inside I
thought you brought her inside yeah
unless you let her but no you didn't let
you let her back out did it I think you
did okay [ __ ] okay well we got to go
find the cat cause it's like really late
so uh okay hopefully you guys enjoyed
this rambling discussion about the
history of circus sideshows and freak
shows and whatever like that which was
episode 181 like I said I was really
excited about doing this topic so I've
been [ __ ] up to you badly remember if
you liked the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media it really does help a lot if you
give us like place out on patreon help
us out on patreon like it really does I
mean everywhere you dollar makes it
every dollar makes a difference now um
if you would rather not deal with
patreon because I know some people
some people sent us like 50 bucks out of
the blue who is that the Senate just 50
bucks out of the blue Jason Jason I know
I said thank you need a man that's
awesome but yeah so if you would like to
just give us a one-time donation that
would also be very much appreciated and
go to our blog 13 o'clock podcast on
wordpress.com and there's a button in
the sidebar sidebar that goes to a
PayPal account that goes right to me so
if you'd rather do that than patron that
is fine as well yeah and by Jenny's
books and sure yeah looks they're super
check her out on Amazon
Jimmy Ashford goes on I am all over the
place I have I have games that I
designed I have books that I've written
I have all kind of stuff you want me to
do graphic design I could do that too
yeah you know multi-talented Renaissance
woman yeah all right so that will do it
for episode 181 we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]